Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt,
Mein Name ist Tim Britt Love und das hier ist Ausgabe 87. Wir haben den 1 Dezember 221 und,
ein Freitag und freitags ist Corona. Weekly und jetzt sind wir mal wieder Weekly, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und ich, ihr wisst es, machen das jetzt hier äh alles schon äh eine Weile. Ähm es ist,
absurd sich äh äh vorzustellen, dass wenn wir das jetzt bis März noch äh durchziehen, äh dann auch irgendwann wirklich
zwei Jahre äh schon zusammengebracht haben werden. Das äh ist ein bisschen absurd, oder?
Ja, das ist äh äh unerwartet und ähm ja auch nicht nicht schön. Ich finde das schöner, wenn wir nicht mehr über covid und Corona reden müssten.
Na gut, aber solange die Leute noch äh der Meinung sind, dass es doch eigentlich ganz schön ist, wenn wir das tun, machen wir das jetzt auch erst mal noch. Ähm an der Stelle.
Also ich habe auch noch mal so ein bisschen auf unsere Statistiken geguckt. Ich messe ja immer, wie viel Downloads es gibt. Das ist dann auch schon alles, was ich messe.
Einfach auch nur um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen und zuletzt hatten wir dann doch schon so was in der Größenordnung von 30.000 Downloads pro Sendungen jetzt innerhalb einer Woche, was ich ganz ähm
bemerkenswert finde, dass das Interesse dann doch ähm da zu sein scheint, hier so ein bisschen Abrundung der Nachrichtenlage zu erfahren.
Insofern fühlen wir uns da auch motiviert äh das äh jetzt noch zumindest noch in der vierten Welle auch fortzusetzen.
Ja ähm.
Genau und äh vielleicht auch noch ähm einerseits danke für alle, die jetzt sich auch entschlossen haben oder es schlimmer getan haben.
Äh UKW regelmäßig auch zu unterstützen mit äh einer äh Spende.
Es gibt jetzt noch eine andere Möglichkeit und zwar habe ich jetzt endlich mal nach langer Zeit mal ein bisschen den Arsch hoch
bekommen und ähm angefangen mal ein paar T-Shirts ähm.
Online zu stellen, die man erwerben kann, unter anderem halt auch ein UKW-Shirt. Falls äh euch also das schöne UKW-Logo schon immer äh ganz gut gefallen habt und ihr euch gedacht habt, so das wäre doch eigentlich mal was für ein T-Shirt, gibt's jetzt.
Link findet ihr in den Shownotes und da könnt ihr euch dann als Klicks an, wenn ihr äh Lust habt, auch das kommt natürlich dann hier der Sendung äh zugute und finde sich auch ganz gut aus. Schönes Siebdruck äh Shirt, bin gespannt.
Demnächst geht's da mit dem Druck los, könnt ihr also jetzt ordern, wenn ihr Lust habt. So, Werbeblock beendet.
Kommen wir äh zu den wichtigen äh Themen. Ähm neuen äh Gesundheitsminister.
Ja
Hast du damit eigentlich gerechnet, dass Karl Lauterbach es tatsächlich wird?
Nicht wirklich ehrlich gesagt. Also ich äh hatte äh eher gedacht äh zu sagen, dass er's ablehnen wird, dass er nein sagen wird. Äh so und mhm.
Wirklich? Oh das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ich dachte nur, dass dass es ihm nicht geben.
Nee, ich äh hatte eher äh damit äh gerechnet.
Mhm. Warum?
Na ja, ist ein kluger Mensch. Ähm ich meine, es ist nicht so geil Minister zu sein in Deutschland, wie sich das alle Leute vorstellen, ja, im Gegenteil, das ist halt ein Kack.
So und eigentlich hätte ich ihn für klüger gehalten, aber äh ja.
Ja gut, aber inwiefern kann's jetzt noch schlimmer werden, als es jetzt für ihn schon ist? Ich meine, er muss jetzt schon von Talkshow zu Talkshow rennen und alles erklären.
Ja, nein, wenn einen der Ruf ereilt äh und es ist halt so, es gibt nicht viele prominente Politiker. Wenn man sich mal überlegt,
äh so von dreiundachtzig Millionen Deutschen, wenn man jetzt äh mal eine namentliche Liste aufmachen sollte von äh.
Tiefen Politikern, die man so kennt gerade. Da kommt man nicht so richtig weit. Also vielleicht, ich sage mal, je nachdem, manche Leute irgendwie scheitern schon bei fünf, andere kommen vielleicht bis dreißig, ja.
Oder manche vielleicht die Felzien schaffen's irgendwie hundert Namen zu nennen. Aber ja eher, ich würde sagen so
zehn oder zwanzig ähähkriegen die meisten Leute zusammen, ja. Ich meine, allein wenn du überlegst, wie schwierig es ist, auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben, wer alles Bundesminister ist, ja?
An der Tat.
Ja und dann äh äh versuchen wir dann die Landesminister noch dazuzunehmen, ja. Man kriegt kaum jemand hin, alle Landes und Bundesminister auf äh zu.
Als Ministerpräsidenten.
Äh nein jetzt sozusagen Senatoren oder oder Landesminister jetzt von deiner Landesregierung.
Ach so von dem eigenen Land in dem man äh.
Genau. Genau.
Ja? Also weil das sind sozusagen also das die für einen zuständigen Bundes- und Landesminister. Dann müssen wir auch noch sagen Karl Lauterbach äh also
Bundesgesundheitsministeriumsministerium ist ja nicht für die Gesundheit.
Zuständig, sondern es ist ja auch so mehr so ein Ding oben äh drüber, sondern es ist ja auch hauptsächlich Länder-Sache. Also Gesundheit. Insofern ist das natürlich auch wieder.
Mehr Hype äh ähm also
ist, ist das Amt, will ich sagen des des Bundesgesundheitsministers. Äh klar, in Pandemiezeiten natürlich jetzt superwichtig, aber äh normalerweise ähm so eher mittelbedeutend.
Gut.
Kannst du dich denn an die ähm bisherigen Bundesgesundheitsminister und Ministerin äh erinnern, so aus den letzten Jahren? Würden dir so spontan ein paar einfallen?
Äh vor Pandemiezeiten nicht also nicht wirklich.
Jens Spahn haben wir natürlich jetzt alle noch eine Erinnerung, ne.
Genau. Mhm.
Wer ist ihm äh vorausgegangen? Also ich habe die jetzt natürlich nachgeschlagen, weil ich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Äh also ich glaube, da war irgendeine Frau hatten wir auch irgendwie als Gesundheitsministerin.
Ja, aber da da bist du dann schon wirklich lange zurück, ne? Das ist schon 15 Jahre her, dass äh.
Mhm, mhm.
Der Posten von einer Frau bekleidet wurde. Nee, also vorher hatten wir Hermann Gröhe.
Ja der war irgendwie.
Merkel vertraut hat, davor äh ging das an die FDP, Daniel Bahr.
Er löste Philipp Rößler ab? Und davor war's Ulla Schmidt von der SPD.
Genau, Ulla Schmidt ist die letzte Bundesgesundheitsministerin äh die mir äh irgendwie äh im Gedächtnis haften
geblieben ist, die ich mit diesem Amt verbinde. Alle anderen so wie ich das, weiß ich nicht habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass sie irgendwas,
Relevantes getan hätten oder so. Zumindest.
Nichts auf äh nichts Relevantes in die Öffentlichkeit gedrungen ist.
Ja, also auch Horst Seehofer war mal Gesundheitsminister.
Mhm. Nö. Mhm.
Äh Rita Süßmuth so und Heiner Geißler, das sind glaube ich noch so die bekannteren so, aber äh ja. Äh du hast.
Ja nicht unbedingt jetzt so die Position in der man äh besonders glänzt. Es sei denn, es hat gerade Pandemie, ne.
Ja ja.
Wobei geglänzt hat der Spahn jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, aber es war zumindest sichtbar.
Ja, meine spontane Reaktion auf äh Twitter äh war ja, hast du wahrscheinlich gelesen. So, ach, jetzt gerade, wo ich gelernt habe, dass man
Fachkompetenz äh und politische Macht,
besser getrennt hält, kriegen wir auf einmal einen kompetenten Gesundheitsminister so und haben gesagt, ich wünschte ihm aber trotzdem viel Erfolg und äh ja.
Das trifft es, aber ich weiß nicht, es können wir vielleicht bei anderer Gelegenheit erläutern äh oder ein Stichwort nur, weil damit die Leute nicht nicht völlig also Stichwort äh Technokraten-Regierung, ja.
Das ist sozusagen die die andere Seite oder warum man meint, dass das nicht so eine gute Idee ist, wenn halt lauter Fachleute
man will halt die Fachleute es unter sich auskämpfen lassen und die Jury entscheidet dann wer von den Fachleuten Recht hat. Ist sozusagen das bessere Prinzip als wenn die Fachleute einfach selber entscheiden
und quasi äh mit ihrer eigenen politischen Macht
ihre fachliche Meinung äh äh durchdrücken, weil es muss ja nicht unbedingt so sein, dass der
und sagen auch der fachlich kompetenteste ist der es geschafft hat die größte politische Macht anzuhäufen du verstehst.
Ich glaube, das hängt so ein bisschen vom Korruptionsgrad ab.
Weil weil wenn du da also jetzt so eine so eine Art Mafiuse äh Struktur am Start hast äh auf Ministerebene, dann dann helfen dir die ganzen Technokraten auf der zweiten Ebene auch nicht viel.
Ich glaube auch Italien hat in den letzten Jahren immer die die Technokraten-Pause äh eher geholfen. Aber äh das führt jetzt gleich ein bisschen zu weit. Auf jeden Fall Karl Latterbach erscheint mir
Also.
Es gibt mehrere Aspekte, weswegen ich das jetzt ganz interessant finde. Einerseits finde ich äh klar, was du schon gesagt hast so. Er macht wirklich den Eindruck, als ob er sich einfach mit diesem Thema, zumindest mit dem aktuellen Primärthema, doch sehr intensiv auseinandersetzt.
Ganz offensichtlich, ne.
Erscheint dann auch so bisschen jetzt der erste Twitter-Minister zu sein, also das ist einfach so so ein Kraft seiner Follower-Schar. Ich meine, wie viele wie viele äh Follower hat er irgendwie auf Twitter irgendwie sechsstellig?
Auf jeden Fall, das das schafft kein anderer äh Politiker. Nicht, dass er sich jetzt irgendwie besonders influenzamäßig bewegen würde, sondern er ist halt einfach ähm.
Aus eigener Kraft so eine ähm so ein sendungsbewusster.
Geworden oder war es schon immer und hat dann einfach das passende Medium in der richtigen Zeit äh auch gefunden. Das ist auch noch mal interessant, weil ich habe schon so den bisschen den Eindruck gehabt, die SPD hat am Ende auch keine Wahl gehabt.
Erstmal wollte det wollten die anderen, glaube ich, das Gesundheitsministerium alle nie haben. So, dann blieb's bei der SPD hängen. Und was bitte hätte er was hätte denn Olaf Scholz anderes tun können als Lauterbach zu nehmen?
Nehmen wir mal an jetzt irgendeine andere unbekannte Person würde jetzt dieses äh Ministerium führen.
Aber was was hätte was hätte er denn tun sollen, wenn Lauterbach nein gesagt hätte.
Dann hätte er sich halt was einfallen lassen müssen, aber dann hält er Lauterbach auch äh auf Nachfrage gesagt, so wollte ich nicht. Das ist ja was ganz anderes.
Ja
Na ja, das war ja bisher bisher immer äh äh wenn er gefragt wurde, äh äh war das eigentlich seine Position lange Zeit. Aber klar, das macht man natürlich auch in der Politik, weil äh der, der immer als Erster genannt wird,
für ein Amt oder oder häufig der der ich sage mal oft ins Spiel gebracht wird, so wird's dann am Ende nicht. Und äh derjenige, der es
irgendwie auch will, äh so äh der kriegt's dann auch oft nicht, was vielleicht ein gutes Prinzip auch ist, weil die will man jetzt nicht
unbedingt die Leute haben, die so geil auf's Amt sind.
Also ich glaube schon, dass er das wollte. Und zwar glaube ich auch, dass er das nicht wollte, weil er geil ist auf Gesundheitsminister ist, sondern weil er einfach die Schnauze voll davon hat, dass.
Dass diese Pandemie nicht richtig gesteuert wird, zumindest aus dem Aspekt Gesundheit heraus, ist ja nicht der einzige Machtbereich, der hier eine Rolle spielt. Und von daher empfinde ich ihn zumindest bisher.
Oder bis hierhin als.
Jemand, der einfach jetzt auch bewusst die Rolle antritt und egal mit welchen sonstigen Schwierigkeiten das noch verbunden ist, das jetzt auch erst mal ignoriert.
Es ist natürlich immer, ich sage mal, das ist natürlich dann immer der größte Glücksfall, wenn du dann jemanden äh hast mit Fachkompetenz
und der Macht und äh er sie halt auch dann richtig nutzen.
Kann sozusagen in in richtiger Art und Weise, aber aus Politik
systematischer Sicht geht man davon aus, dass das eher die Ausnahme ist oder ein Glücksfall äh ja.
Einfach ein Risiko äh darstellt, weswegen du halt einfach lieber einen Haufen Fachleute ohne Macht haben willst und ein paar Leute
mit Macht, aber äh die vielleicht.
Trotzdem gut denken können, aber die sich dann irgendwie von dem einen oder anderen Fachmann überzeugen lassen. So das ist das sozusagen eine stabilere Konstellation, als dass du immer drauf setzen musst, dass du halt fachlich kompetente äh äh Leuten
TÜV äh die auch noch die richtige Moral äh und Integrität mitbringen für einen,
Posten äh so dieses, wie gesagt, das ist zwar ein Riesenglücksfall, wenn das passiert, aber äh das ist nichts, worauf du eigentlich dein politisches System basieren lassen möchtest.
Trotzdem denke ich, dass Olaf Scholz jetzt gar keine andere Wahl hatte, weil man stelle sich jetzt mal vor, er hätte halt jetzt also angenommen Karl Lauterbach wollte den Job und ich nehme das eben jetzt auch an, weil äh sonst hätte er ihn auch nicht genommen. Ähm.
Anders hätte jetzt überhaupt gar keine Chance gehabt. Ich meine, du hättest jetzt irgendeinem Bundesgesundheitsministerin gehabt, die hätte irgendwas gesagt und dann wären alle sofort zu Karl Lauterbach gegangen und haben gefragt, ja was halten Sie davon?
Entweder ist er derselben Meinung, dann ist es okay.
Es ist.
Oder er ist anderer Meinung und dann ist äh äh vorbei. Also das Ding war äh durch. Und was ich so persönlich.
Am interessantesten finde ist, also er ist ja irgendwie auch ein totaler Nerd und ich habe ja ein Herz für Nerz.
Ja, er ist so Spot-on und und irgendwie voll im Thema und äh kann dann einfach auch,
gut argumentieren und tut es sogar halbwegs empathisch. Also an der Stelle greift das Nürtingen vielleicht gar nicht so richtig,
und die wird ja jetzt alles mögliche nachgesagt, was irgendwie unter Umständen für so eine Kabinettsdisziplin problematisch sein könnte und so, aber ich denke, es gab einfach überhaupt keine andere Wahl. Also könnte auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam äh werden. Wir wünschen ihm auf jeden Fall alles Gute.
Ähm oh gucken wir mal wie's läuft.
Ja äh das äh erinnert mich dann jetzt,
an eine Sache oder so ein paar Dinge, die jetzt passiert sind, nämlich wie ich sage mal auch gefährlich rumnörden äh auf
Twitar sein kann, wenn man auch so einen Haufen Follower hat, weil äh die nicht alle Nerds sind äh oder
mit einem ganz anderen äh Mindset äh sozusagen rangehen, weil als Nerd.
Tendiert man eher dazu bestimmte so äh äh Varianten gedanklich äh äh durchzuspielen oder bestimmte Aspekte äh rauszuheben.
Die ja einfach ein bisschen nerdig sind und ja,
Das haben halt bei verschiedenen Gelegenheiten jetzt Leute glaube ich definitiv in den falschen Hals äh gekriegt und wir kommen da später äh noch drauf äh äh.
Bei dir jetzt oder bei Karl Lauterbach?
Bei mir auch und bei Karl Lauterbach mit Sicherheit, deswegen kann ich das halt ganz gut
fühlen. Das ging halt bis äh sozusagen, dass ich sogar tatsächlich jetzt einmal irgendwie äh
äh ja äh man eine Cancelling äh äh Kampagne äh gegen mich gefahren hat. Hatte ich ja auch glaube ich schon erwähnt, so wo meine Follower angeschrieben worden sind mit irgendwie, was ich denn da Schreckliches getwittert habe und sie mögen mich doch
entfolgen.
Ach so echt wirklich.
Ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Oder was?
Ja, ja, ja. So läuft das dann. Äh genau.
Ah krass.
Und habe mir dann einer halt äh so eine DM, die er gekriegt hat, halt zugeschickt,
äh so. Ja und ich habe dann so ein bisschen die Debatte mitbekommen, so war's ja halt nur 50 Follower verloren irgendwie. Jetzt müssten mindestens tausend sein. Strengt euch mehr an, Leute.
Ja ja und das hat dann
äh äh es hat dann gut ich habe dann irgendwann mal nachgeguckt, ich meine ich mache das ja hier nicht wegen einer wegen der Follower oder so. Das hat's mich dann doch interessiert so und äh ich glaube es war ein temporär irgendwann mal glaube ich zweihundert Leute oder so, die mich dann entfolgt
haben, aber äh so in der Zeit sind da weiß ich nicht fünfhundert dazugekommen oder so, deswegen äh ja oder,
kurz danach, insofern,
Aber es ist ich ich fand's nur irgendwie wirklich interessant, weil ich hatte das bisher immer nur davon gehört, dass es sowas gibt und äh jetzt habe ich das mal selber erlebt. Ähm ja,
aber das äh lässt ja, das hält mich jetzt nicht davon ab,
äh irgendwie weiter auf Twitter so meine äh äh meine Gedanken äh zu streamen teilweise so meine Gedankenströme, die vielleicht nicht auch immer super geordne.
Äh sind oder so, aber äh wo ich zumindest das Gefühl habe,
doch ja äh einige Leute da schon ein bisschen was draus ziehen können und dass ich halt dann schon irgendwie so mal ein paar Wege abseits beleuchte oder so ein paar Gedankengänge ähm,
bringe die nicht so ganz mitten im Mainstream liegen, aber ich glaube, ich bin auch kein Extremist.
Ja also insgesamt ist seine Followerzahl ja durchaus äh leicht angewachsen, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ich habe grad mal bei mir nochmal nachgeschaut, ob gegen mich irgendwie grad noch irgendeine Kampagne gefahren wird, wenn's eine gibt, scheint's ja auch gerade nicht zu helfen. Zu funktionieren.
Na ja ja.
Corona, da war ja noch was. Äh wir wollen heute mit euch äh natürlich wieder reden über.
Also mit euch, für euch reden über.
Den Stand der Dinge Zahlen klar wir reden über Impfkampagne kurz und dann wollen wir vor allem
auch nochmal zutragen, weil da ist diese Woche doch eine ganze Menge passiert von den Bedenken, dass es interessant ist, das mal zu sinnieren, äh was denn das alles bedeuten könnte.
Ja und fangen wie immer mit den Zahlen an. Pavel, wie sieht's denn aus? Inzidenzen, Inzidenzen.
Ja, also es sieht so aus, als äh wenn äh wir tatsächlich erst mal einen vorläufigen.
Inzidenzpeak erreicht haben. Wir haben
jetzt so R-Werte von unter eins, also deutschlandweit jetzt bei null Komma neun sechs äh Gerade und die Inzidenz ist jetzt von äh.
Einem einem Peak äh vor zwei Wochen so, der der fast bei fünfhundert lag, jetzt auf vierhundertsiebenundvierzig gefallen.
Nach äh ja jeweils nach Publikations äh Datum gemessen. Ähm.
Die Zahl der Todesfälle äh steigt aber weiter an und hat mir in den letzten sieben Tagen 2500 Fälle so. Das ist äh natürlich nicht so schön und da ist noch keine,
Trendwende in Sicht. So. Aber was man eben auch dazu.
Sagen muss, ist, dass hm ja im Vergleich jetzt zur vorletzten Welle,
die äh Zahl der Todesfälle auch nur ein Sechstel der äh äh.
Der Inzidenz beträgt wie ähm also im Vergleich zur Inzidenz wie,
ja zu der großen Welle vor einem Jahr. Ähm,
Aber damals ging halt auch die Inzidenzen nur bis 240 rauf
und äh die Todesfälle dann halt bis ja 6000 in der Spitze hatten wir
da in in sieben Tagen aber ja es wird auf jeden Fall jetzt noch in die in die Höhe gehen erstmal.
Und dann kann man später drüber reden äh dann was was Omikron denn jetzt mittelfristig eigentlich bedeutet.
Genau, also wir sind ja noch in Delta Country und ähm man sieht halt hier die Auswirkungen der Impfung letzten Endes, ne? So kann man das, glaube ich, klar interpretieren. Nur ist halt nicht genug geimpft äh gewesen, sonst hätten wir auch nicht so viele Todesfälle.
Und was man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch sagen kann, wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, äh wie sieht's in den Altersgruppen aus? Äh haben wir halt nach wie vor
bei den fünf bis vierzehn Jährigen so eine Inzidenz von neunhundertachtzig äh aber auch fallend so von ja äh von fast elfhundert
runter äh noch vor zwei Wochen und auch in allen
anderen Altersgruppen bis auf eine, nämlich die Null bis Vierjährigen sinken auch die Inzidenzen, während sie in der Altersgruppe der Null- bis Vierjährigen
noch weiter steigen, aber auch verlangsamt äh steigen. Also sagen der Rückgang äh jetzt der Inzidenzen betrifft
aller Altersgruppen. So und
ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt fragt, okay warum? Ich denke, äh durchaus ja weniger
Kontakte spielen sicherlich eine Rolle, höhere Maskendisziplin, aber ähm
ja äh auch irgendwelche Faktoren, die wir nicht nicht genau benennen können, das kann irgendwie das Wetter sein, das Verhältnis von Luftfeuchtigkeit äh zu Temperatur oder irgendwelche Verhaltens
Änderungen. Mir ist jedenfalls aufgefallen, dass äh in der Gastronomie äh jedenfalls jetzt.
Deutlich weniger los war als ich das letzte Mal draußen war, aber äh punktuelles ist auch noch ganz schön äh durchaus Trubel, aber generell glaube ich äh ja sind die Leute vorsichtiger geworden.
Klar und es gab ja auch Verschärfungen durch die zwei-G-Regelung, also das ist ja.
Drei G im äh PNV und Bahnen. Gut, das wird wahrscheinlich kaum kontrolliert werden. Trotzdem ist es ja dann auch ein Signal und das wissen wir ja schon von von Anfang an.
Oft ist es eben so, dass allein schon Ankündigungen und die ähm sagen wir mal so das Zentrum der politischen Diskussion was so thematisch gerollt wird.
Dazu beiträgt und in dem Moment, wo halt über.
Ein Lockdown, der zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen wird, eine Impfpflicht, die jetzt nicht mehr ausgeschlossen, sondern eben auch teilweise äh schon beschlossen worden ist. Das hat natürlich alles seine
Wirkung auch auf die Psyche und ich denke auch, Leute werden vorsichtiger. Nur der R-Wert liegt halt bei 0,neunfünf. Das ist jetzt noch nicht so.
Das ist noch nicht genug, ne. Wir bräuchten halt so was wie 0,7, um wirklich nennenswerte Verbesserungen herzustellen. So können wir bestenfalls die Sache äh weiter köcheln lassen und das ist eigentlich immer noch too much.
Definitiv und,
es gab ja auch äh immer noch Spekulationen, ja ist denn jetzt der Rückgang wirklich real oder ist es jetzt nur wieder irgendwie ein Artefakt von.
Testen und äh da kann man aber sagen äh das ist auch entschieden. Wir haben auch eine rückläufige positiven.
Quote äh und insofern äh ja ist der ist der Rückgang auch
real, ja würde ich äh äh sagen, dass es jetzt kein Artifakt
äh weil weil Inzidenzen jetzt sind jetzt so hoch, dass jetzt die
Ämter nicht mehr mit ihm melden und testen äh äh nachkommen und deswegen so aber das äh ist nicht äh der Fall. Also dafür gibt es jedenfalls keine Anhaltspunkte. Das mag hier und da örtlich äh so der Fall äh sein, aber
nicht im relevanten Ausmaß. Ja was äh die jetzt noch was die Bundesländer angeht oder hattest du jetzt noch irgendwas Wichtiges?
Würde ich jetzt auch gerne drauf äh hinleiten, weil auf der einen Seite haben wir halt diesen Ausreißer bei den äh bei einer bestimmten Altersgruppe, äh ne, also ähm was was fünf bis.
Null bis vier.
Nein äh nicht nicht denen, dass es nicht zurückgeht, sondern die höchsten Inzidenzen haben wir im fünf bis vierzehn Bereich, ja. Also da ist halt mit diesen 9achtzig der totale Ausreißer äh und der andere Ausreißer heißt Sachsen. Aber es geht zurück.
Stimmt bei den, ja, bei den Bundesländern äh geht's fast überall äh zurück. Ähm.
Wobei ja Sachsen-Anhalt hat eigentlich eher so die Kombination äh da ist noch äh setzt die Trendwende noch nicht äh so recht ein. Brandenburg äh,
pendelt sich gerade irgendwie auch auf hohem Niveau ein.
Also sagen wir mal hier die Top vier, ne? Also Sachsen tausendzweihundertfünfzig, Thüringen, tausendeinundsiebzig Sachsen-Anhalt, tausendvier. So, das,
Also das ist erstmal die Top drei, die ganz klar hier äh anführen ist in dem Sinne ja auch nix Neues, wissen wir alle schon. Sachsen-Anhalt, Thüringen, Sachsen das halt einfach so, dass das Pandemiezentrum äh in gewisser Hinsicht
dann passiert halt eine Weile lang nichts. Dann kommt Brandenburg noch mit 729 äh hinterher und dann kommt so der Rest gestaffelt äh,
Baden-Württemberg, Bayern, MV Saarland, Berlin et cetera und so weiter und am Ende halt Schleswig-Holstein.
Ja Bayern und der Osten ziehen den Schnitt hoch, also ziehen die liegen über dem Deutschlanddurchschnitt.
Und Baden-Württemberg.
Ah ja stimmt das ist recht ja Bayern Baden-Württemberg
und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern äh ist äh das einzige unterdurchschnittliche Land, liegt aber äh im Osten, äh liegt aber fast äh auf einer Ebene mit dem Deutschlanddurchschnitt.
Und äh ja.
Berlin ist auch im Osten. Man sieht auch drunter.
Ja, aber Berlin gilt nicht so. Ist nicht so richtig Osten.
Berlin ist nur so halber Osten. Ja, Berlin war vorher irgendwie auch.
Das ist für dich so eine Selbstwahrnehmung aus Berlin, die kann ich zwar absolut nachvollziehen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das alle Hörerinnen mitteilen. Ist schon Sonderfall, aber es.
Nee, doch, also du kannst es, du kannst es schon, ja ja, Berlin ist halt einfach Berlin, das ist halt nochmal so ein so ein Spezialfall.
Oh
Ich meine, Berlin gehört halt zu den Regionen in der Welt, äh wie auch wenn ich Kalifornien ist auch so. Äh die Hälfte der Leute, die in Berlin oder in Kalifornien leben, sind da nicht geboren. So.
Das ist auch nicht im Bosten.
So, während sozusagen der typische Osten ist halt glaube ich genau umgekehrt. Ich meine, da sind nicht so viele hingezogen.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn man die hierher zieht, egal wo wo, egal woher man kommt, wenn man hier erstmal eine Weile lang wohnt, übernimmt man irgendwann zu diesen diese Selbstverständnis des Sonderstatus von Berlin ganz automatisch. Da kann man gar nix gegen tun.
Genau. Genau und dann ja und dann am Ende wird einem noch irgendwie Arroganz vorgeworfen oder so.
Tja, wie kommen die da überhaupt drauf? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Genau genau Niveau sieht nur von unten so aus wie Arroganz.
Oh.
Ja, also es kommt von dem Hamburger habe ich das irgendwie, die Hamburger sind da eigentlich noch ein bisschen krasser, aber äh ja. Ähm.
Okay, lass uns weggehen von den Bundesländern.
Mein Freund Alex bringt halt immer irgendwie solche Sachen. Wie gesagt also die Hamburger finde ich sind irgendwie einfach äh unübertroffen. Also die toppen noch die Berliner.
Das äh ja mehr auf so eine äh ja subtile Art äh und wie auch immer.
Okay, lass es dir auf die positiven Quote kommen und was Positives zu vermelden haben.
Äh
Also Tests ähm oder wolltest du noch mal du hast es ja schon erwähnt, ne? Also wir haben etwas weniger Tests als letzte Woche, wo wir so viele Tests hatten wie noch nie. Aber immer noch gut 1,9 Millionen.
Und die Positiv-Quote ist gefallen von 21,04, was die höchste war, die wir bisher überhaupt hatten.
Auf 20,85 ist auch mal noch viel zu hoch.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also immerhin geht's runter und bisher war es so, immer wenn sie runterging, ging sie erst mal auch eine Weile runter.
Das heißt natürlich erst mal gar nichts. Wir müssen schon wieder auf diese fünf Prozent kommen oder zumindest so perspektivisch ähm damit wir dann überhaupt
den Eindruck haben, dass wir das Infektionsgeschehen äh noch verstehen und ähm ja, das wird ja demnächst eh noch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ja.
Was man immer im Hinterkopf behalten muss, ist, dass äh je höher die positiven Quote umso höher in der Regel auch die Dunkelziffer, das heißt eigentlich müsste man
die positiven Quote dann äh immer noch mit einem wenn ich ja exponentiellen äh Faktor äh aufschlagen.
Krankenhäusern aus.
Ja also auch da äh sieht es so aus als wenn
des äh leicht rückläufig ist so die Hospitalisierungsinzidenz wie so schön äh heißt, wobei es da ja auch äh mit der Meldekette,
immer wieder gewisse Probleme gibt, aber,
im Moment äh scheint sie auch wieder regional unterschiedlich, aber im Moment scheint sie zu sinken, ist aber im,
Berlin zumindest nach der nach der Ampel äh ist es gerade rot. Ähm.
Deutschlandweit kann man sagen ähm,
Ja, geht geht's ihr auch jetzt wieder zurück? Seit der 46 Kalender äh Woche und ja die.
Die höchste Hospitalisierungsinzidenz haben wir halt bei Ungeimpften,
60 plus, da liegt sie bei fünfundvierzig, während sie in allen anderen Altersgruppen geimpft oder ungeimpft halt ähm,
weniger als ein Viertel beträgt so. Ähm äh und ganz oben sind halt die ganzen äh.
Ungeimpften, also.
Ungeimpfte 18 bis 59 Jahre liegen, liegen fast bei bei zehn äh bei zehn, nicht Prozent, sondern 10 pro 100 000 und.
Ja, erst dann kommen die vollständig Geimpften mit 60 Plus.
Und alle anderen Altersgruppen äh geimpft oder ungeimpft äh liegen halt irgendwo bei 3 von 100.000 und.
Ja
Aber äh man merkt halt äh trotzdem, dass gut wir haben ja leider jetzt nicht bei den bei den Impfungen nicht nicht die verschiedenen Alters äh.
Oder nur diese drei Altersgruppen, aber man kann auch äh ganz klar sagen, dass die Hospitalisierungsinzidenz bei jungen Leuten, also wo mit der Statistik zwölf
äh bis zehnsieb
macht auch nochmal einen Faktor von sechs, sieben, acht äh aus, das heißt auch bei mindestens zwölf bis Siebzehnjährigen hat äh die Impfung ein äh riesigen Schutz äh so hat,
bietet auch die 80, neunzig Prozent Schutz, also es ist nicht so wenn man jetzt sagen würde
äh ja bei jungen Leuten macht das keinen Unterschied, sondern er macht's äh teilweise auch nochmal fast einen größeren Unterschied zwischen Impfung und und Nichtimpfung, was jetzt
Hospitalisierung angeht
selbst wenn's absolut niedrig ist so macht es halt trotzdem relativ einen Riesenunterschied.
Ja.
Ja, gut. Haben wir noch was zu Zahlen?
Nö, bei den Zahlen äh äh denke ich, werden jetzt auch wieder nicht dazugekommen, äh international groß äh vorzubereiten, obwohl wir das eigentlich versprochen hatten, aber.
Dafür haben wir noch gleich einen Südafrika Spezial.
Okay, das das.
Dann äh vielleicht noch ein Blick auf die aktuellen Fortschritte der Impfkampagne.
Auch da gibt's nicht wirklich viel äh Neues zu vermelden. Ähm die.
Also wir haben zwar.
Einen äh Rekord jetzt äh tatsächlich in den letzten sieben Tagen, sind also im Wochenschnitt äh glaube ich sogar fast mehr,
durchgeführt worden als zur Hochphase im Juni Mitte Juni. Nur das sind natürlich zu.
Nicht gerade wie viel Prozent gefühlt 80 Prozent sind das halt alles Booster-Impfungen. Das heißt, die Leute.
Die, die sozusagen, die man jetzt impfen, nicht erklären muss, warum das eine gute Sache ist, so.
Die große Mehrheit stürmt grade, Arztpraxen, Impfzentren, mobile Impfgelegenheiten, die hier und da aufpoppen.
Und ich merke das auch so in meinem Umfeld, wie ähm da schnell vernetzt irgendwie Termine hin und her geschoben werden oder Vakanzen weitergereicht werden.
Ja und das führt dazu, dass eben sehr viele Leute sich jetzt grade boostern lassen und das äh halte ich auch für eine eine sehr gute Geschichte. Die Praxen sind entsprechend auch überlastet.
Impfzentren nehme ich an, äh ist es ähnlich, aber da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt grade gar nicht so viel unmittelbares Feedback bekommen. Da hätte ich mich noch mal ein bisschen rumhören müssen.
Ja, ich habe so ein so ein bisschen was was gehört äh auf Twitter und ich hatte ja auch nun äh den äh dringenden Wunsch, mich Bostern äh zu lassen, habe aber irgendwie ein,
paar Tage zu spät äh gewartet und in denen hatte sich dann irgendwie die haben sich dann komplett alle Termine auch in den Impfzentren so in Luft aufgelöst und die waren dann alle plötzlich bis Februar ausgebucht.
Und dann habe ich aber auch äh ja auf äh Twitter erfahren, dass dann den äh Pankow ähm,
so da im Einkaufszentrum am Sonntag, dass da äh auch geimpft wird und weil irgendwie auch Adventssonntag war und auf war, haben die auch am Sonntag geimpft und dann äh bin ich da,
unverzüglich hin, habe mich aufs Motorrad gesetzt und äh hatte dann
Glück, weil ich kam dann grade, als sie am Zumachen waren und äh haben dann freundlicherweise
ja noch die die letzte Dosis, die sie noch hatten, die sonst in den Müll gewandert werden, an moderner, stattdessen irgendwie in meinen Arm
noch gespritzt äh sodass ich dann durch diesen Glücksfall und äh Twitter dann spontan äh ohne warten zu einem Booster gekommen bin, worüber ich dann sehr,
sehr glücklich war.
So, ich stand dann trotzdem so ein bisschen hatte ich das Gefühl, wieder zwei, drei Tage so ein bisschen neben mir, also.
So bei mir, bei den bei den mRNA-Impfstoffen habe ich das Gefühl.
Setzt da so ein leichter Brainfog ein, sage ich mal, aber der der wirkt sich jetzt nicht unbedingt darin aus, dass dann
meine Gedankengänge in kohärenter werden. Es fühlt sich dann nur so ein bisschen ja neblig an äh alles. Keine Ahnung. Aber das war dann nach zwei, drei Tagen äh eigentlich wieder.
Komplett weg. Ähm ja.
Äh das hätte ich ja mal gerne. Also ich habe ja auch bis zum heutigen Tag nix gemerkt.
Mhm.
Ich weiß auch nicht, gehe wahrscheinlich bin ich wahrscheinlich sowieso super immun gegen alles.
Ich mache nichts von meinen Impfungen und auch ansonsten ja.
Irgendwie nix groß gespürt, einen Schnupfen hatte ich mal. So, das war's bisher.
Ja ich hatte hatte nur in ganz leicht dann auch einen wunden äh Arm, so wenn ich drauf äh gedrückt habe. Was mich dann aber beruhigt hat war mir klar, okay, wir haben's wirklich in den Muskel gespritzt und nicht in der Vene und äh.
Okay, das hatte ich dann auch noch. Also so an der Einstichstelle habe ich auch schon äh gemerkt, dass da reingestochen wurde, dass da irgendwas am werkeln ist, aber ich habe jetzt,
was weiß ich, bin nicht müde geworden, bin ich geschwach geworden, ich habe kein Fieber gehabt oder sonst irgendwas. Äh ich werde deswegen auch nächste Woche habe ich einen Termin, wenn ich mal meinen Antikörper mal messen lassen.
Jetzt doch mal wissen möchte, was passiert ungefähr vier Wochen nach meiner Busterei. Ähm ja,
um zu gucken, was was dabei rauskommt. Freund von mir hat es auch machen lassen nach seiner zweiten Impfung nach
vier, fünf, vier oder fünf Monate, ich glaube fünf Monate, vergangen waren und da waren die Werte extrem niedrig.
Sodass ja da auf jeden Fall angesetzt war. Also nicht bei jedem schlägt es gleich gut äh an. Ich sage jetzt nicht, ihr müsst jetzt alle losrennen.
Und äh gucken äh wie viel Antikörper ihr habt, weil die Antikörpermessung ja auch nur, was so im Blut rumschwimmt äh nimmt und nicht unbedingt hier zu groß äh auf Teezellen et cetera äh ch.
Sie ist kein direkter Indikator, aber da äh ja waren wir da jetzt jetzt auch schon äh drauf kommen auf das Thema Wirkung äh Wirksamkeit von Impfungen.
Ja, also zumindest was so bei Boostern ähm.
Äh noch bekannt geworden ist. Grundsätzlich, was jetzt diesen Abstand betrifft, vielleicht noch mal zwei äh Sachen. Also einerseits gibt's ja.
Viel Diskussion da drüber was für ein Abstand denn jetzt eigentlich angesagt sein soll
Ja, also wir hatten ja mit sechs Monate gestartet. Das war dann auch die erste Aussage der EMA. Das hat die STIKO auch übernommen, wobei die natürlich erstmal wieder nur für Vorerkrankte und überhaupt und man muss ja ganz vorsichtig sein und
impfen überhaupt alles ganz komisch. Äh dann äh war der Andrang so groß. Ja und es war auch ein bisschen absurd, weil alle Leute.
Ja Winter alles gefährlich passt auf,
Also ja, wie wär's mit Boostern? Hm ja, aber erst später, also habt ihr sie noch alle? Und dann ja, aber die sechs Monate und dann gab's halt irgendwie fast kaum Leute, die irgendwie sechs Monate schon durch hatten, weil das äh ne also Ju,
war die große Welle so wat wollt ihr eigentlich? Dann ist es hier und da auf fünf Monate gewechselt worden, dann,
haben die Leute, dann sind sie wieder weggeschickt worden, dann wurde es auf fünfeinhalb Monate hochgesetzt, also ist jetzt so ein bisschen die Berlin Perspektive, wo es die ganze Zeit hin und her ging, ja.
Äh dann doch wieder fünf Monate und jetzt gibt's auch ganz viele Impfstellen, die sagen ja irgendwie so ja hier ab drei oder vier Monaten alles kein Problem, totale Konfusion äh impfen wieder irgendwelche Ärzte nicht, weil sie Angst haben, dass die Haftung nicht übernommen wird und so weiter.
Und ähm mittlerweile hat dann jetzt die die EMA, ich glaube auch bei der WHO ist das mittlerweile so, die sind ja der Meinung so, ja ah nee so Boostern haben wir uns mal angeguckt und so ist eigentlich nach drei Monaten auch schon ganz sinnvoll.
Ah okay, gut, super. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht die Empfehlung, dass nach drei Monaten zu machen.
Sagt so, ja, so halbes Jahr wäre ganz gut, aber schatt jetzt auch nix, so ab drei Monaten sehen wir eben diese gewünschte Wirkung. Was mir halt so sagt, so ja okay, gut, dann.
Gibt es doch mal frei.
Also mittlerweile ist ja sagen ist ja die Ansicht äh setzt sich die Ansicht durch, dass eine volle Impfserie aus drei Shots äh besteht so. Ja also.
Und äh man weiß jetzt nicht, wie lange das anhält, aber dass es sozusagen mit also mit drei Shots äh kriegt man dann äh richtig,
krassen Schutz hin.
Genau, also es gibt auch Ausreißer hier Landkreis Lüneburg, habe ich gesehen, äh die sagen auch wer wer Boostern will, kriegt und äh der Abstand muss nur vier Wochen betragen.
Also da geht's irgendwie in die ganze andere Richtung und dann äh fand ich noch sehr interessant. Malte Kreuzfeld, der ist ja auch hier alles sehr äh extrem,
begleitet alles. Der hat mal nachgerechnet und geguckt.
Okay, was kriegt denn Deutschland eigentlich an Lieferungen? Was ist denn sozusagen im Lieferplan, was tatsächlich an Impfstoffen geliefert wird? Wie viel ist da? Und hat das mal ausgerechnet und ähm so ein bisschen,
Davon ausgegangen, dass die Erstimpfung nicht weiter ansteigen werden, was sie auch nicht getan haben bisher, sondern die sind äh gefallen. Das habe ich jetzt eben noch gar nicht gesagt. Also wir haben zwar viel Booster, aber wir haben halt rückgehende Erstimpfungen, ne?
Nachdem sie schon immer generell niedrig waren, also da passiert grad noch nicht viel, da muss glaube ich noch ein bisschen mehr.
Bei stabil würde ich sagen. Also ist das ein leichter Anstieg oder? Ganz äh bei den Erstimpfungen.
Ich glaube, du hast eben eine Chance gerade noch auf die falsche äh Grafik, das war nämlich noch die aus der letzten Woche. Die sind mittlerweile wieder ein bisschen zurückgegangen. Die ersten Impfungen und ähm siehst du die mit der gelben Linie?
Mhm. Ja, okay, mhm.
Also die sind hochgegangen, sind wieder zurückgegangen, ähm das muss man gucken. Ich denke, hier hängt's jetzt einfach von der Absprache ab und äh äh Ansprache ab und davon, wie sehr jetzt äh mit der Impfpflicht wirklich
ernst gemacht wird. Auf jeden Fall Malta hat nachgerechnet und festgestellt, also ausgehend auf einer gewissen Erwartungshaltung für Erst- und Zweitimpfungen. Zwei Impfung lässt sich ja sehr gut einschätzen, Erstimpfung,
sieht man, bleibt niedrig. Ähm so viele.
Impfdosen werden geliefert im Dezember und stehen sozusagen zur Impfung bereit, so sie den ordentlich verteilt werden. Das mit diesem Fünf-Monats-Regime überhaupt gar nicht alles weggehen würde.
Ne? Gut, ist natürlich noch die andere Frage im Raum, haben wir jetzt derzeit eigentlich die Kapazitäten zu zu impfen. Ja, also gibt's genug offene Impfzentren et cetera, aber wir sehen ja, wir haben jetzt eine Woche gehabt, die so gut war wie die beste Woche im Juni.
Alle Impfzentren offen waren et cetera. Also es ist zwar eine Anstrengung, aber es geht und.
Er meint, wenn wir nicht das den Abstand auf vier Monate senken. Überhaupt gar nicht genug Leute.
Da sind, die jetzt geboostert werden dürfen.
Es wäre auch dringend äh.
Fohlen oder sogar notwendig irgendwie das Jetzt zu tun, äh so ähm solange wir auch noch äh ja im äh äh Delta-Regime äh sind
äh sage ich mal, das ist die eine Sache, weil äh irgendwann,
ja irgendwann wird's halt auch gar keinen Sinn mehr machen. Äh äh die die aktuellen Impfstoffe äh noch zu verimpfen, aber dazu kommt man dann vielleicht.
Später noch. Äh also im Moment auf jeden Fall. Also äh sagen, ist eigentlich eigentlich müsste bis Weihnachten irgendwie jeder der.
Geboostert sein möchte oder oder kann äh eigentlich auch geboostert äh werden. So und auch ich denke,
Was war das? Drei Monate war halt oder Monat äh sagtest du.
Lüneburg haben sie gesagt, vier Wochen Abstand.
Vier Wochen Abstand, ja. Ja, scheint gelingt sinnvoll. Hm, ich selber würde vielleicht irgendwie eher zwei Monate warten, aber äh ja ähm.
Genau.
Ja, die Kinderimpfung haben jetzt auch äh wenn also es gibt jetzt Termine und äh das geht am 15. Dezember geht's los.
Ja
Was bringt äh die Boosterei? Da gibt's noch mal eine eine interessante Studie aus Israel. Da gab's ja schon äh mehrfach solche Unternehmungen
einfach auch nochmal äh klar darlegt, dass wenn man halt geboostert ist, dass ähm das einfach zu 90 Prozent vor,
Todesfall schützt, also eine sehr sinnvolle Ergänzung ist.
Ja, ich meine, wir wir brauchen mittlerweile gar nicht mehr nach Israel zu gucken, sondern wir haben ja jetzt auch äh die Zahlen für Deutschland, die ja jetzt seit,
einiger Zeit dann auch vom äh RKI veröffentlicht werden. Die stehen natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen in der Kritik, aber äh sagen für die.
Äh sogenannte Hospitalisierungsinzidenz äh so werden dann die Zahlen erhoben und ähm,
sodass man äh dann auch äh jetzt in den verschiedenen Altersgruppen äh,
in den wir Aussagen über die Impfquote machen können, was halt im Moment nur die drei sind über sechzig äh ja unter achtzehn oder äh halt dazwischen. Und äh da,
kann man aber gucken, sieht man halt, äh wie gut,
jetzt im Schnitt äh bei dem aktuellen Impfstand, der Bevölkerung oder äh äh ja.
Ähm wie gut das dann vor Infektionen schützt, vor Hospitalisierung, vor ähm Intensivstationen oder vor Tod.
Und ähm da haben wir wie gesagt jetzt mittlerweile einen ganz guten Überblick und.
So äh um jetzt mal konkrete Zahlen zu nennen, die ich jetzt auch äh nachgerechnet habe, die schwanken zweimal von Monat bis Monat zu Monat, aber haben jetzt nicht wirklich einen einen erkennbaren Trend, sondern das geht halt alles rauf und
und runter um ein paar Prozent. Aber der Schutz jetzt in der Altersgruppe sechzig Plus, äh wo das äh,
das so am relevantesten fand, äh natürlich ist der äh Schutz vor Infektion rund 47 Prozent.
Was halt einen Schutzfaktor von 3,85 entspricht. Das heißt, hm, bei.
Ungeimpften ist äh die,
Inzidenz 3 Komma acht fünf Mal äh so hoch wie unter Geimpften, ja. So, wenn man jetzt dann äh.
Hospitalisierung nimmt und da ist es jetzt wichtig bei diesen Prozentangaben, weil
das hat bei mir auch erstmal eine Weile gebraucht, bis ich das im Kopf auseinander sortiert hatte. Ähm du.
Hast ich sag mal so nach Logik oder.
Hast hast du so was wie eine Gesamtwahrscheinlichkeit oder Gesamtinzidenz, das heißt jetzt bei der zum Beispiel bei der Hospitalisierung äh ist es jetzt so, dass.
Das vor Hospitalisierung bei sehr über 60-jährigen zu 86 Prozent schützt die Impfung,
Das ist ein Faktor von 7,zwoacht. Vor Intensivstationen sogar zu über 90 Prozent so. Also Faktor von über zehn.
Und vor Tod immerhin noch achtundachtzig Prozent mit einem Faktor von acht Komma vier, ja. Alles.
Sehr hoher Schutz äh äh sage ich mal so, aber das gilt halt,
quasi für den Gesamtschutz. Das heißt, das gilt halt sagen äh alles nicht äh äh oder nur äh äh solange du dich nicht infizierst.
In dem Moment, wo du dich jetzt infizierst, bleibt halt aber noch ein weiterer Schutz statistisch gesehen, weil dann kannst du gucken, okay
von denen, die sich infiziert haben, wie viel von denen wurden denn hospitalisiert, hatten einen schweren Verlauf oder sind dann gestorben?
Und da kommt man dann äh wenn man den rausrechnet jeweils den Schutzfaktor kommt man bei Impfstoffen,
oder bei Geimpften auf einem Hospitalisierungsschutz von 47 Prozent,
also ungefähr Schutzfaktor zwei, eins Komma neun, genauer gesagt äh vor schwerem Verlauf, also Intensivstationen äh zu,
63 Prozent Faktor von ungefähr 2,8 und vor Tod,
von vierundfünfzig Prozent, also einen Faktor von zwei Komma zwei ja? Und die kannst du dann jeweils
mit dem sozusagen Faktor äh äh sagen Infektionsschutz nämlich 3,8 5, diese 5 74 Prozent multiplizieren und dann kommst du auf diese Gesamtschutzfaktoren von
um die 90 Prozent vor Hospitalisierung, Intensivstation oder Tod, ja. So setzt sich das halt zusammen und,
Das ist halt insofern relevant. Ich meine.
Äh es gibt natürlich durchaus Korrelationen. Es ist immer die Frage, kann das wirklich alles so auseinanderrechnen, aber ich denke schon ähm.
Und ähm das ist natürlich einmal relevant
für die die Frage OK wenn denn jetzt eine neue Variante unseren Schutz umgeht oder wenn ich halt einfach unvorsichtig war und mich dummerweise doch
infiziert habe, äh so welche Chancen bleiben mir denn dann? Und es gibt natürlich auch einen anderen Wirkungsmechanismus.
Der hängt zwar teilweise zusammen, aber es ist ja so, dass der Infektionsschutz eher durch die neutralisierenden Antikörper äh kommt, die quasi verhindern, dass der Virus überhaupt erst in die Zellen äh eindringt und sich überhaupt.
Breit macht. Wir während dieser,
Langzeitschutz äh also wenn vor Hospitalisierung, Intensivstation oder Tod, wo man ja auch immer sagt, ja der hält halt auch länger, das ist ja die T-Zell-Antwort.
Die kommt halt erst, wenn die Infektionen äh sich wirklich breit gemacht hat. So wenn tatsächlich,
Zellen äh Befall zeigen. So
und äh ja insofern äh denke ich ist das schon relevant sich das einfach mal vor vor Augen
zu führen und man in in jedem Fall äh so lohnt sich das, das Impfen und das Boostern allein schon wegen Delta und vermutlich dann
auch äh sagen als Schutz vor Omikron, wo wir wo wir dann noch noch kommen, aber.
Hm der Schutz ist glaube ich geringer, wenn man sich das so in diesen Prozentzahlen.
Anguckt als viele Leute wahrscheinlich vermuten. Also.
Sprich, äh wenn es zu einer Durchbruchsinfektion kommt, dann schützt mich als über 60-jähriger im Schnitt
ja stirbt trotzdem die Hälfte oder sterben halt zwar nur halb so viele äh von den Leuten oder etwas weniger als halb so viele, wenn sie sich infiziert haben, wenn sie geimpft haben, aber eben
trotzdem immer noch halb so viele, ja? So und äh das äh heißt halt dann.
Bei doppelt so hoher Inzidenz habe ich dann trotzdem wieder die selbe Anzahl an an äh Todesfällen, selbst wenn die Leute geimpft sind, wenn es zu,
Impfdurchbrüchen kommt äh und äh die Impfdurchbrüche, das ist natürlich auch so eine statistische äh Geschichte, weil äh.
Wenn ich halt Impfung und Maske und Kontaktreduzierung halt aufeinander äh packe, dann habe ich halt einen äh,
gigantisch höheren Schutzfaktor und die in dieser Kette äh macht dieser äh der der Impfschutz
äh ja nicht immer unbedingt das Größte äh Glied aus, sondern Masken sind halt vergleichbar äh gut
und äh ja Kontaktreduzierung oder Treffen lieber draußen als drinnen. Ähm so da komme ich dann locker zusammen auf Schutzfaktor
dann von tausend und und und mehr, wenn ich das kombiniere gegenüber einem Schutzfaktor von zwei, wenn ich mich auf meine Impfung verlasse äh ja oder einem Schutzfaktor von drei Komma acht
äh äh muss sagen
komplett oder selbst selbst die ja selbst die neunzig Prozent oder die Schutzfaktor zehn oder Schutzfaktor 1000 ist dann schon ein deutlicher Unterschied.
Ja.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall äh.
Sollte sich sein lassen, ganz klar, wir brauchen das auch, es ist wichtig ähm allein schon um so die Ankunft von Omnibron.
Bisschen abzufedern, weil sonst schlägt's noch mal extra heftig auf und das ist halt äh auf jeden Fall hilfreich.
Noch hilfreicher wäre natürlich die Impflücke äh wirklich geschlossen zu bekommen. Ne, da werden wir nochmal gleich drüber reden, wie äh Deutschland das jetzt vielleicht anstellen kann.
Ja, darf ich vielleicht kurz noch äh dazu äh etwas einwerfen, also weil wir sagen ja jetzt bei Ratschlägen äh äh waren. Also mein,
Ratschlag äh wäre sich äh unbedingt Boostern äh zu lassen.
Oder impfen zu lassen, falls man noch nicht geimpft sein äh sollte,
aber sich nichts darauf einzubilden. Ja, also man sollte sich äh dann, man sollte sich boostern lassen und sich dann so verhalten, als äh wäre man äh ungeimpft,
und ähm infiziert. Ja. Auch wenn man gerade einen frischen Test dazu hat.
So. Das ist ungefähr äh denke ich und warum äh da kommen wir dann später noch im Zusammenhang auch mit
äh um Mikronährvariante, warum ich glaube, dass das äh ja das richtige äh die richtige Verhaltensempfehlung ist.
Boostern, aber sich nichts drauf einbilden.
Ja ähm was jetzt demnächst sicherlich ein Thema nochmal werden wird, ist natürlich dann die Auswirkung der Impfung von äh jüngeren Kindern äh.
Ich denke, wir sollten uns langsam auch verabschieden von dieser Vorstellung, dass Corona-Kindern nichts anhaben kann.
Ja klar, das sind weniger und äh gerade im Bereich Todesfälle ähm.
Spielt es nicht so die Rolle. Das ist wirklich die totale Ausnahme. Aber was sich abzeichnet und auch da verlinken wir nochmal eine Studie aus Israel. Ähm,
dass dieses long covid schon noch ein Problem sein kann. Ja, also da gibt's vor allem den Bericht, dass dass äh long covid vor allem mit milden Verläufen,
zusammengeht. Also das, was am Anfang erst mal mit ah ja milder Verlauf, alles nicht so schlimm, äh beginnt. Ähm.
Kann auch bedeuten, dass das dann später erst einsetzt.
Das muss man einfach echt im Kopf haben und von daher alle die jetzt auch noch so überlegen sind so Kinder impfen und so.
Macht das bitte. Ja, auch die äh fünf plus und es wird auch nicht mehr so lange dauern. Ich denke mal im Frühjahr werden wir dann auch die Impfung für ab Null haben.
Geht jetzt äh ganz fix und es ist auch alles ganz äh äh wichtig. Erspart euern äh Kindern eine Infektion. So ihr das überhaupt noch könnt.
Mhm. Ja, das Problem bei ab ab null dürfte aber auch äh sein. Äh dass halt im ersten
Lebensjahr die Kindersterblichkeit äh irgendwie fast zehnmal so hoch ist äh wieder nach. Das heißt äh wenn ein Kind irgendwie erstmal das erste halbe Jahr oder das erste Lebensjahr
überstanden hat. So dann äh ja sinkt die Sterblichkeit äh rapide. So. Das Problem.
Ist, aber dann äh ja ähm gerade bei der sagen wir mal einen
die Statistiken im Moment, die wir die wir erheben, haben dann so, ja, von null bis fünf äh Jahren äh die null bisvier Jahre die Altersgruppe äh
kannst du die ganzen Covid-Effekte wegen dieser hohen Sterblichkeit äh nicht nicht wirklich messen oder oder erkennen und da geht halt tatsächlich auch noch was anderes.
Vor. Das heißt, da da kann man äh im Grunde genommen gar nicht wirklich auf,
die Zahlen warten oder wird wird es nie äh wirklich genau wissen oder oder gut wissen können oder es wird wird halt sehr sehr schwierig.
Das zu tun, aber bei aber alles ab äh fünf Jahre so, da hatte ich jetzt ich sage mal, kein Problem,
dort tatsächlich äh eine ganz klare.
Ja Wirkung auch zu sehen oder oder gesundheitliche Auswirkungen äh auf die Sterblichkeit äh und eine klare Abhängigkeit von der Inzidenz, also in dem
Alter sind halt immer, wenn die Inzidenzen angezogen sind, sind auch mehr Kinder gestorben. Auch wenn sich die Zahlen an einer Hand ablesen lassen, ne. Nur.
Wenn nur halt zwölf Todesfälle hast in einem äh in einem Mehr von äh also insgesamt in einem Meer von, ich weiß nicht, tausend Todesfällen oder so. Da kriegst du halt statistisch nur ganz schwierig was was raus.
Gut das bringt uns jetzt zur Impfpflicht. Denn Hauptproblem ist natürlich jetzt wir müssen irgendwie es schaffen die Leute, die noch nicht geimpft sind, zumindest zu einem Großteil dazu zu bringen, sich impfen zu lassen.
Die Gründe warum sich Leute nicht äh impfen lassen, haben wir nun schon.
Viel gesprochen und ist auch ein bisschen müßig, muss ich sagen. Also es ist mir persönlich mittlerweile auch eigentlich egal.
Erstmal kurz die News. Also wir haben jetzt ein neues Infektionsschutzgesetz. So. Das ist jetzt vom Parlament beschlossen worden.
Der neuen Parlamentsmachtverteilung mit der Ampel jetzt in der Regierung, ist auch im Bundesrat einstimmig angenommen worden.
Und äh damit kommen im Wesentlichen eine ähm Impfpflicht für Leute in äh Pflegeeinrichtungen, also Mitarbeitern in Pflegeeinrichtungen.
Also und Krankenhäusern, also quasi medizinisches Personal. Im Detail weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, wo da jetzt.
Die Grenze konkret gezogen wird, aber hier geht's vor allem um Altenheime, Pflege, ne, in im weiteren äh Sinne. Die Leute haben also Zeit.
Bis Mitte März ähm sich vollständig impfen zu lassen.
Ja und wenn sie das nicht äh tun, dann können sie halt in diesem Job nicht tätig sein.
Ganz einfach. Von Strafen habe ich jetzt noch nix gelesen. Das ist jetzt erstmal so eine Vorschrift für.
Beruf um diesen Beruf ausüben zu können, ist das einfach die Voraussetzung, wenn man die Voraussetzung Mitte März nicht hat, dann kann man sie im, kann man diesen Beruf eben nicht ausüben.
Ja ich finde das jetzt nicht wirklich exzessiv äh so muss ich sagen.
Aber es wird zu Problemen äh führen. Das äh kann ich,
schon sagen, es wird dazu führen, dass je nach Beruf äh ein größerer Teil tatsächlich hier einen Job aufgeben wird.
Ja, also das wird sich zeigen, würde ich sagen. Also in anderen Ländern, wo das eingeführt wurde, hat es jetzt nicht zu massiven Kündigungen geführt.
Und wenn das dann so ist, dann äh ist das halt so. Es kann aber auch genauso gut dazu führen, dass andere Leute da wieder reingehen, weil sie das Gefühl haben, sich jetzt nur noch unter äh Mitarbeitern zu befinden, die irgendwie dieselbe Voraussetzung äh als erfüllt sehen.
Ja ist ein möglicher äh Effekt.
Es ist so ein klassisches kann sein, weiß man nicht und wird man auch nicht rausfinden, bevor man's nicht probiert, aber die Argumente sprechen halt klar dafür. Und außerdem, denke ich mal, ist das auch nur ein erster Schritt.
Wir werden an dieser allgemeinen Impfpflicht nicht äh vorbeikommen. Was im Infektionsgeschütz im Infektionsschutzgesetz auch noch steht, ist, dass jetzt die Impfereien nicht nur von.
Äh
Ärzten durchgeführt werden dürfen, sondern es schließt jetzt auch Zahnärzte, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen bisher nicht dabei waren, warum auch immer. Äh Tierärzte.
Und äh auch Apotheker mit ein.
Da bin ich noch gespannt, welche Apotheken sich da auf diesen Zug äh werfen werden. Ähm ist ja sagen wir mal in Deutschland nicht unbedingt typisch für Apotheken, dass solche.
Dort durchgeführt werden. Andererseits ähm denke ich mal haben die äh die notwendige Qualifikation und ähm.
Brauchen einfach jetzt jeden Ort, wo irgendwie Impfungen verabreicht werden können. Es geht halt einfach nicht mehr so weiter, dass dass wir einfach.
Nicht impfen können und Leute, die sich also es kann nicht sein.
Dass wenn's viele Leute gibt, die sich impfen lassen wollen, dass sie's deshalb nicht tun,
ums Verrecken keinen Termin irgendwo finden, weil es einfach zu schwierig ist, ein Angebot äh wahrzunehmen. Es scheint sich jetzt stellenweise schon verbessert zu haben. Ich meine, die Aktion von dir, von der du jetzt grade erzählt hast in in so einer Shopping-Maul?
Was war das in so einem leeren Laden oder was oder wo fand das statt oder.
Nee, ich glaube, das war der äh Jahr, es war in einem also in einem Laden äh wo der arme
Arbeiter-Samariterbund irgendwie 2 Ärzte und
weiß ich nicht fünf, sechs, sieben andere Leute so mit Security und mit wie äh Administration und so und konnten also quasi zwei Leute gleichzeitig äh immer
impfen oder oder bearbeiten, sage ich mal, mit irgendwie,
dann markiert ein Stehposition noch in der äh äh für die Schlange äh davor und keine Ahnung welche Kapazität äh
man äh damit hat aber wahrscheinlich schaffen die so irgendwie keine Ahnung hundert, 200 Leute am Tag würde ich sagen könnten die da.
Hast du denn dein Zertifikat auch gleich bekommen.
Nee. Äh das äh äh muss ich mir in der Apotheke holen, aber ich habe halt äh halt ja Paperwork und Kleechen äh irgendwie bekommen und ich,
war da jetzt auch nicht äh äh sage ich mal Hauptsache Booster ja äh so weil.
Ja ja klar, nee, aber ich habe das nun von verschiedenen auch von Arztpraxen gehört und so weiter, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht in der Lage sind oder äh immer noch nicht in der Lage sind, diesen äh dieses Zertifikat zu generieren in dem Fall oder sich das äh einfach nur ersparen wollen, sondern die Apotheken weiterreichen.
Na ja gut.
Gut, also das ist jetzt eben das neue Infektionsschutz äh Gesetz erster Ansatz Impfpflicht ist da und ähm ich denke halt, sie wird kommen in Österreich wiederum, ist ja auch beschlossen worden, da ist es ja eine richtige Impfpflicht, die gilt dann schon ab.
Und da gibt's dann halt auch schon entsprechende Strafen und zwar ähm Verstoß gegen die Impfpflicht dreitausendsechshundert Euro
Strafe.
Mhm. Ja.
Aus der man sich aber raus impfen kann. Also wenn man's irgendwie sozusagen versäumt hat, kann man zumindest bis zu einem bestimmten ähm Zeitraum.
Ähm wird das Verfahren sozusagen also wenn man sich dann sozusagen trotzdem impfen lässt, dann dann.
Muss man's dann doch nicht zahlen, aber das droht sozusagen.
Ja mir ist letzte Woche so ein prinzipielles Problem noch mit der mit der Impfpflicht,
aufgefallen äh nämlich äh was so ja ähm Motivationspsychologisch äh ein Problem darstellt und zwar.
Weiß man halt, dass äh wenn,
man's jemanden zu etwas motivieren will, dann ähm ist es besser ihn äh zu belohnen, weil also wenn man jemand.
Aktivieren will und Strafen funktionieren besser, wenn man jemanden passivieren will. Also wenn man jemanden davon abhalten will
irgendetwas zu tun. So, was jetzt nicht heißt, dass du jetzt nicht auch mit Strafen,
Leute dazu veranlassen kannst, etwas zu tun und mit Belohnungen, Leute etwas äh veranlassen kannst, etwas nicht zu tun, aber
du musst dich halt mehr anstrengen, wenn es nicht nicht ist ja? Und die also du hast halt große Unterschiede jetzt in der in der Effektivität.
Ähm und die zweite psychologische Prinzip ist, dass ähm bei Strafandrohung.
Erstmal ähm du dich nicht in der Rolle bist, bestraften fühlst. Während bei,
Belohnung, wenn ihr eine Belohnung in Aussicht identifizierst du dich sofort damit, ja? Klar habe ich Anspruch auf diese Belohnung, weil ich habe ja irgendwie das getan, wofür man belohnt werden soll und deswegen
zu ja äh aber
so wenn's ums Bestrafen geht die Leute eher so leer ich nicht irgendwie ich bin nicht so wie die anderen irgendwie. Äh ich verdiene die Strafe nicht, weil ähm.
Na gut, können sie ja behaupten, aber hilft erstmal nicht.
Und äh wie gesagt, es ist ich ich will nur sagen, es ist halt eine.
So nicht nicht die aller äh effizienteste
Art und wenn dann Leute noch äh wie im Fall jetzt von diesem ja von dieser Berliner Tragödie wo äh irgendwie jemand in die Querdenker Szene geraten ist und dann anschließend seine Frau und seine drei
Töchter umgebracht hat äh aus Angst vor ja äh Verhaftung oder weil ihm die Kinder weggenommen äh äh werden,
weil er irgendwie Impfzertifikate vielleicht gefälscht hat und drohte seinen Job äh zu verlieren äh deshalb und so.
Und gut, letztlich halt dann auch mehr wenn man Haupt äh Grund dann auch ja äh.
Angst vor, keine Ahnung, Scham sozialer sozialem Abstieg, Ausgrenzung, wie auch immer. Und äh wir sagen, wenn die Leute erstmal sich sich da eingegraben haben,
ähm in ihrer äh Position, dann äh kriegt man sie da äh ohnehin nicht leicht raus und vielleicht noch als letzter Punkt, Motivationstheoretisch.
Was halt dann komplett auch die ganze Psychologie des, ich sage mal, BHviorismus irgendwie eigentlich zertrümmert, ähm ist, dass am besten.
Belohnst oder bestrafst du die Leute äh also nimmst du sowohl von Strafe als auch Belohnung Abstand sondern äh guckst halt, dass die Leute irgendwie intrinsisch
äh motiviert sind, weil das zeigte sich dann nämlich bei Studien, so wo man rausfinden wollte, funktioniert jetzt Strafe oder Belohnung.
Besser, also wie wirkt sich Straf oder Belohnung auf die Produktivität aus bei einem äh bei bestimmten Tätigkeiten oder Arbeiten?
Und dann stellte man fest, ähm ja, Belohnung irgendwie funktioniert besser als bestrafen.
So, aber dann hat man noch mal Test reingemacht mit WO ohne Belohnung und Bestrafen. Ich stellte fest, dass die Produktivität dabei noch höher war als äh sodass sozusagen auch Belohnung eigentlich eine.
Äh Desintensivierung äh äh sein sein kann. So aber leider ist es nun mal versäumt worden.
Ähm irgendwie bei vielen Leuten diese intrinsische äh Motivation dann herzustellen oder zu wecken, so wo.
Dann einfach ja der Lohn in der Sache selbst äh liegt, also im sag mal im ehrenhaft.
Das sich ja im im Geimpftsein so noch nicht mal äh durch den Schutz, sondern der Schutz wäre quasi auch nochmal eine Belohnung, aber
ähm ja einfach nur das Gefühl des Geimpftseins oder den den Beitrag zu leisten zum äh äh im im Kampf gegen das Virus, ja und für seine Nachbarn und für das Land.
Bei uns ist das ja auch so. So, also das ist ja.
Dass das generell nicht funktioniert, sondern das ist halt bei manchen ist es halt so und bei manchen ist es halt so. Und klar, äh ich kann das gut nachvollziehen, dass eine Belohnung für manche Leute eben auch.
Attraktiver ist als eine Bestrafung, ja? Und es gibt ja auch vieles sieht man ja jetzt auch in der ganzen Diskussion, die sich dann halt noch mehr eingraben und so, ja jetzt erst recht und so. Nur die machen da auch auf mich nicht so unbedingt so den Eindruck, als ob man die über irgendeinen anderen Weg noch bekommen würde.
Da ist dann ohnehin Hopfen und Malz verloren.
Die die Frage, die ich mir nur gestellt habe, äh so hat man eigentlich alle anderen Optionen ausgeschöpft.
Oh nein, da hat man natürlich nicht, ne. Also das auf keinen Fall.
So, das ist das ist sozusagen mein das ist meine Kritik äh daran. Meine Kritik richtet sich weniger
gegen die die Impfpflicht jetzt an sich äh sondern dass man eigentlich das was sozusagen
letztes Resort sein sollte, eigentlich erst dazu greifen sollte, wenn man sagen alle anderen Mittel ausgeschöpft hat und
da ist nichts ausgeschöpft worden so ja das ist das das finde ich das Verwerfliche oder suboptimale an der Situation.
Auch ganz bei dir und ähm das ist auch etwas, was äh verbessert werden muss. Ich meine, auch hier ist, sagen wir mal, der Regierungswechsel jetzt insofern natürlich jetzt auch ganz gut.
Weil ich der Meinung bin, die neue Regierung macht alles besser.
Ja, die wird auch was vergeigen, aber es ist zumindest neu. Ja, das heißt, äh für die gibt's jetzt erst mal nix, wofür sie sich schämen muss, wenn man jetzt mal ausblendet, dass die SPD auch Teil der letzten Regierung war.
Aber das so wird das ja auch nicht gesehen, so neue Regierung, neues Glück, andere Partner, andere Absprachen, andere Zwänge. Jetzt können sie im Prinzip frei aufschlagen und
gibt so einer neuen Regierung, auch zumindest jetzt weiß nicht, ob's jetzt auf hundert Tage hinauslaufen wird, aber sagen wir mal, so zumindest haben sie jetzt mal einen Monat, wo erstmal so sich sortieren können.
Ähm so dass man eben jetzt die Dinge auch einfach verbessern kann. Und es gibt ja auch gute Beispiele. Es gibt das Beispiel Bremen.
Schon ein bisschen überstrapaziert, aber Bremen hat eben sehr viel getan. Also erstmal indem sie.
Mit sehr vielen mobilen Impfteams losgezogen sind. Sie haben auch sagen wir mal ganz einfache Fehler nicht gemacht.
Wie die Leute, die nicht so gut Deutsch sprechen, zu adressieren. Sie haben halt einfach diese Informationen in allen erdenklichen,
Sprachen produziert. Bin jetzt auch mit der Impfkampagne in Bremen nicht so auf per du, aber.
Das ist das, was ich so mitbekommen habe. Es wurde einfach aktiv auf die Leute zugegangen, angeschrieben. Es wurde mehrsprachig gearbeitet. Also man hat da nicht so einen
hochnäsiges Jahr, äh wieso? Äh äh ihr ihr Termin lag doch äh mehrere Wochen in einem Computer auf einer Webseite, deren URL sie nicht kennen,
bereit, was wollen sie denn eigentlich? Ja, so die dann aber im Zweifelsfall down ist, wenn man draufklickt oder einen irgendwie wahnsinnig macht. So, ich hatte vorhin auch grad wieder den Fall, weil natürlich jetzt geht's rum hier mit Kinder äh Terminen
ein Freund von mir twittert so oh ja hier voll geil Kinder Impftermin gefunden, gar kein Problem, richtig viele Termine da. So
ich schiebe das irgendwie eine Minute später einem anderen Freund rüber, der klickt rum so hier ist überhaupt nix,
Also die ganze Experience ist halt einfach total dystopisch und man hat einfach die ganze Zeit dieses Gefühl, man muss dem hinterher rennen.
Ja und auch zum Beispiel auf Doktor Lip äh die Suche nach einem Termin. Da wurden dann zwar jede Menge Termine bei Ärzten.
An geboten. Aber nachdem man sich dann durchgeklickt hatte, wurde einem erst im allerletzten Schritt gesagt, ja nee, aber äh nicht für Neupatienten.
Äh statt dass du statt dass du einfach das als Suchkriterium mit äh äh angeben kannst beziehungsweise mach das überhaupt eigentlich gar keinen Sinn äh Termine anzubieten auf einer allgemeinen Webseite.
Die äh nicht für äh die.
Nicht für allgemeines Publikum gedacht sind, sondern nur für Leute, die dort Patienten sind, ja. Das würde ich dann,
übererwarten, dass das dass die Termine dann über die Webseite des Arztes angeboten äh werden, aber wüsste nicht, was sie dann jetzt äh sagen, dazu suchen haben, ja.
Warum kann man warum muss man überhaupt auch so suchen? Ja also
impfen und so weiter, ja. Hier hier hast du drei Impfzentren zur Auswahl. Welche Setzinger? Ja mir doch scheißegal. Suche mir halt eins aus. So und äh wenn mehrere Termine verfügbar sind, dann bieten wir halt mehrere Termine an. Dann kann ich mir das immer noch aussuchen.
Muss ich da überhaupt hingehen? Warum muss ich überhaupt suchen? Warum kann ich nicht einfach nur sagen, ich bin Person X und ich würde mich gerne impfen lassen und schicke mir eine Scheiß-Mail, wenn's soweit ist. Aber das,
das das funktioniert halt einfach nicht und das das ist natürlich so ein generelles
Problem, weil wir ja nun schon auch oft äh besprochen, hat auch viel mit der Digitalisierung zu tun hat, was damit zu tun, dass jedes Bundesland seine eigene äh äh Suppe köchelt, alle irgendwie andere Interfaces, andere Gepflogenheiten, Regulatorien, Vorschriften.
Termingrenzen und so weiter haben.
Und Auswahl ist Grund, also zu viel Auswahl ist ja auch.
Ja
Gibt's ja dieses schöne Beispiel, wie viel ich sage mal wie viel Sorten äh Senf hättest du gerne irgendwie in einem im im Supermarkt irgendwie eine fünf- oder fünfhundert, ja? Ähm da wird's dann relativ klar, dass du irgendwie nicht
äh normalerweise irgendwie ja mit 500 Sorten
äh ist einfach allein nur äh zu gucken, welche welche Sorten da sind überfordert einen ja schon.
Da will man das einem so ein bisschen äh der Supermarkt schon die Arbeit abgenommen hat und irgendwie fünf äh vernünftige Sorten da reingestellt äh hat ins Regal.
Also ich denke es ist viel zu gewinnen und es ist auch so für diese intrinsische Belohnung schon ganz wertvoll. Erstmal mach's einfach, mach eine klare Ansage,
Hilf den Leuten dabei, anstatt es ihnen noch äh schwer zu machen,
so ein Frustrationspotenzial wie dieses, man kommt dann irgendwie dahin und dann erzählen die einem, äh das irgendwie, aber ja deine sechs Monate sind ja erst in 24 Stunden rum und so und deswegen können wir dich jetzt nicht impfen, als ob das,
irgendeinen medizinischen Sinn machen würde. Ähm all diese ganzen Härten müssen weg.
Ähm ich meine wir schaffen es die gesamte Bevölkerung.
In einem Tag in ein Wahllokal äh äh zu bringen und äh wählen zu lassen.
So, ich meine äh und so eine so ein Impfvorgang.
Jetzt dauert jetzt auch nicht länger als eine Wahl. Das kann sogar schneller gehen. Ja ähm so du hast halt dann.
Vor allem, wenn alle schon vorregistriert sind.
Genau, alle sind schon vor registriert äh so. Äh du äh zeigst halt deine äh Impfeinladung äh so und äh es wird doch wohl auch möglich sein. Sag mal, wenn man.
Sozusagen genug Personal anzutrainieren oder äh aus ja Ärzteschaft äh Pflegern
äh äh Tierärzten, Apothekern und äh sonst äh äh und irgendwie Medizinstudenten sage ich mal zu zu rekrutieren
ähm und das so zu besetzen,
mit mit zwei Leuten, die impfen können. Mehr ist ja auch typischerweise nicht. Also mehr Kabine oder drei, ja? Und dann hast wüsstest du doch eigentlich die ganze Bevölkerung an einem Tag durchimpfen können oder mache ich da einen Denkfehler gerade.
Ja, also bestimmt. Also grundsätzlich finde ich, hast du äh Recht so, ne? Es gibt natürlich noch ein paar andere Aspekte dabei zu bedenken, weil du brauchst ja erstmal ausreichend qualifiziertes Personal.
In dem Fall diese Impfung auch durchführen und im Zweifelsfall halt auch noch eine ärztliche Beratung äh leisten können.
So, das heißt, du brauchst schon eine sehr große Zahl von Ärzten, aber es zwingt einen jetzt auch keiner. Die ganze Bevölkerung innerhalb,
eines Tages vollständig innerhalb von acht Stunden durchzuimpfen.
Manchmal kann auch 12 oder 16 Stunden äh hm.
Ja einer Woche.
Ja würde sich auch keiner beschweren auch irgendwie so in in vier Wochen wäre das irgendwie alles gut. Es es geht ja eher um den Ansatz wie organisiert man das Ganze. Und vor allem was mir sehr gut gefällt an deiner Idee ist, dass es eben auch,
Es gibt ja dann das Impflokal mit der Betonung auf lokal, ja? Das ist dann halt bei dir um die Ecke.
Genau. Also und ich ich ich bleibe äh einfach äh dabei, dass es,
ich ich sehe nicht, warum das nicht gehen sollte, ähm sagen die gesamte Bevölkerung an einem Tag zu impfen. Ja.
Bereutest du auch die entsprechende Impfstoffmenge also Wahlzettel zu verteilen ist auch ein bisschen einfacher als äh zu kühlende Impfstoffe in ausrei.
Na ja.
In Berlin kriegen sie das mit den Zetteln schon nicht auf die Kette.
Ja, aber es ist auch komplizierter mit den Zetteln, weil mit den Zetteln müssten ja verschiedene Zettel an die verschiedenen Wahllokale gehen. Hier muss so einfach nur also ja, das ist äh klar. Äh äh ist das dann,
logistischer Aufwand und wahrscheinlich auch eher das Problem ähm dass man vielleicht nicht so viel Impf äh Stoffe jetzt,
einen Schlag hat, aber lass es irgendwie auf zwei, 3 oder.
Man muss es ja nicht exakt genauso machen, aber der mindset sollte derselbe sein und das äh ist schon richtig.
So also ja.
Ja, aber was äh um es vielleicht noch mal abzurunden jetzt, ähm wir sind ja hier eigentlich mit der Impfpflicht eingestiegen und.
Wie gesagt, ich sehe sie halt nach wie vor kommen. Ich finde äh
klar, solche Abwägungen mit Belohnung äh et cetera sollte man machen und man kann sich eben jetzt überlegen
Art von Belohnung jetzt hier auch noch zusätzlich mit ins Spiel kommen. Also es muss ja auch kein Entweder-Oder sein. Es kann auf der einen Seite sagen, okay, es gibt jetzt eine Pflicht, weil Leute, wir haben's jetzt irgendwie echt probiert. Es kommen einfach nicht genug Leute äh zum Impfen. Ihr habt irgendwelche diffusen äh Gründe. Manche mögen durchaus berechtigt sein. Die meisten sind's wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich.
Äh es gibt eine Hardcore-Minderheit, äh die aus nicht mehr überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehbaren Gründen des Impfen ablehnt.
Ist vielleicht auch nicht zu retten, aber die ist auch am Ende nicht das Problem, sondern da gibt's einfach so eine Restmenge, die ist schon irgendwie zu kriegen. Und wir sagen jetzt einfach, Impfen ist verpflichtend.
So, aber wir machen's euch auch gleichzeitig jetzt mal sehr einfach. Und wir machen das,
So wie du das jetzt grade gesagt hast mit dem Impflokal äh einfach dann eben so für die Ungeimpften.
Natürlich jetzt auch organisatorisch schlecht aufgestellt, weil wir haben kein Impfregister. Wir wissen nicht, wer nicht geimpft ist. Wir wissen nur, dass irgendwie eine Zahl von Leuten nicht geimpft ist.
Können sie mittlerweile nicht mehr anschreiben. Aber man könnte jedem das Angebot machen und sagen, hier zack, jetzt klickst du hier ist hier ist dein hier ist dein Code,
Und wenn du Erstimpfungen haben willst, dann an dem Tag bei dir um die Ecke und musst hier nur draufklicken und dann ist dein Impfstoff reserviert.
Machbar wäre äh das äh sicher alles. Ähm ich habe mir.
Anlässlich dessen nochmal Gedanken gemacht so oder versucht das Mindset der ich sage mal Impfunwilligen.
So äh doch etwas mehr zu ergründen, weil äh,
sagen, es ist es tut sich natürlich leicht sozusagen, okay, die haben nicht äh die haben nicht alle an der Waffel, die haben irgendwie jetzt äh völlig irrationale,
Ängste entwickelt oder irgendeinen Glauben irgendeinen Quatsch, aber irgendwas stimmt an denen nicht im,
stimmt bei denen nicht im Kopf, ja? Äh die sind sind irgendwie dumm. Ja äh wie
ähm irgendwie Dennis äh äh irgendwie mal so schön äh sagte so eine eine der schwierigsten
Dinge im Leben äh äh es zu erkennen, äh dass wer anderer Meinung ist, äh nicht
ein. Er sagte Fläming Ediat äh ist, also nicht äh irgendwie komplett bekloppt ist und ähm so und ich.
Habe schon immer versucht, aber seitdem.
Tue ich es halt noch mehr versuche ich eigentlich zu ergründen. Okay, wenn jemand irgendwie jetzt so eine völlig mir äh schwer begreifliche Meinung
hat zu etwas, dann äh dem halt auf den auf den Grund zu gehen und
dann kam mir so ein Gedanke wie man das vielleicht verständlicher machen kann oder wie man sich vielleicht besser in äh sagen,
unwillige hineinversetzen kann, nämlich indem ich äh halt sozusagen Impf-Skepsis verglichen habe mit Angst vor Atomkraft
oder Angst vor äh gentechnisch äh modifizierten Nahrungsmitteln so. Das sind.
Aus meiner Sicht auch zwei so Ängste, wo wenn du dir die Statistik anguckst äh du siehst, dass äh ja die.
Bedrohung oder die Gefahr, äh die davon ausgeht im Vergleich zu anderen Bedrohungen oder Gefahren äh wirklich minimal ist. Aber die Angst oder das Unbehagen vor Atomkraft oder
eben äh Gentechnik auch bei mir muss ich sagen äh sind die
eher gefühlt äh unheimlich, ja, so diese Strahlung äh und so, aber ich bin ja dann
sagen wir mal fast zehn oder 15 Jahre lang bin ich ja ständig mit einem Geigerzähler äh im im Rucksack äh rumgelaufen, auch immer auf internationalen Flügen und wir haben auf äh
Piratenvorstandssitzung in Berlin immer dann den Hintergrundstrahlungspegel äh mit protokolliert im im Protokoll und so und ja und dann äh ich sage mal in 15 Jahren äh bin ich.
Äh das Ding.
Nur Alarm geschlagen im Flieger und das jetzt nicht, weil da irgendwie gerade wieder so ein russischer Polonium-Killer oder so mit an Bord war, sondern weil äh du einfach äh durch die Höhenstrahlung, das ist sozusagen die die krasseste Strahlenquelle, die man so mitkriegt.
Und dann manchmal im
Gebirge oder in bestimmten Gegenden äh Gebirgigen Gegenden wo du dann halt oder in Höhlen, wo dann ein bisschen mehr Radonn äh Konzentration ist, die man dann vielleicht das zwei oder dreifache der
Hintergrundstrahlung, aber äh ja. Deswegen äh und ich hatte eigentlich auch noch gesagt, okay äh das bedeutet jetzt nicht,
sozusagen auch weil's statistisch jetzt nicht so gefährlich ist. Äh es sagt jetzt nichts darüber aus, ob man jetzt,
Atomkraft haben will oder nicht, sondern der Mechanismus oder äh sagen diese Ängste, die bei vielen Leuten zum Beispiel vor Atomkraft da sind, sind halt.
Ja nicht mehr oder weniger rational als die Ängste der Leute vor Impfung, weil auch bei den Impfungen äh,
sehen die Statistiken äh sehen halt gut aus, aber
was das ist und so richtig, die können Leute können auch nicht sehen, wie wie das wirkt. Das macht dann irgendwie komische Dinge in meinem,
und äh irgendwie ja es wollen einfach manche Leute äh äh schlichtweg,
nicht oder fühlen sich ja unheimlich und fangen dann natürlich an jede Menge Gründe zu suchen und zu finden äh um um das Ganze zu rationalisieren.
Und bei Gentechnik ist es halt noch noch krasser, ja. Es gibt irgendwie keine
Gentechniktoten in dem äh äh Sinne und wir haben jetzt auch nach äh ja wie viel Jahren gehen
technischer Manipulation äh ist jetzt kein super Organismus entstanden, der jetzt plötzlich äh ja ökologische Katastrophen oder so hervorgerufen hätte, sondern.
Äh die äh Organismen äh die also genetisch modifizierte Organismen haben.
In der Regel gegenüber natürlichen Organismen
äh so weniger Überlebenschancen die sind und was wir im Bereich jetzt der Agrareiindustrie machen äh das sind halt Organismen, die auch so modifiziert sind, dass sie halt unter ganz bestimmten von uns hergestellten Lebensbedingungen sich entwickeln, aber in dem Moment, wo du
aufhörst, ihnen bestimmte Stoffe zu geben oder einzusetzen, ja? Werden die halt sofort äh von der Natur äh äh
ja überrannt äh und und out competet äh und ähm wie gesagt, was nicht heißt, wenn,
du jetzt denkst, okay, was ist denn jetzt der Worst Case so, was ist das Schlimmste, was was möglich ist, keine Ahnung, dann sehe ich irgendwie russische Wissenschaftler, wir wissen die dann,
so
was war das Ebola mit irgendwie Pocken äh gekreuzt haben und so äh und ähm.
Haben Sie gemacht oder ist jetzt nur so.
Ne ne haben Sie gemacht, haben Sie gemacht. Also es gibt da eine Geschichte so von dem Wissenschaftler, der halt äh diesen Job hatte, das das zu tun so. Der halt
Geschichte.
Erzählt und ist immer auch so ein Ding so äh ja äh wie Verantwortung also Wissenschaftler und sagen ethische Verantwortung äh und und so. Sie wissen schon und.
Ja aber wir haben gesagt wenn du dir die Sicherheit von genmodifizierter Nahrung oder so an also wir haben
ohne Ende äh Skandale ja mit mit äh Bio äh äh Nahrung so wo dann Kontaminationen Kolibakterien keine Ahnung äh sonstige Vergiftungen ähm also da muss.
Also ja die Toten im Lebensmittelbereich, die wir haben, kommen nicht von genudifizierten Organismen, äh sondern halt
äh von natürlichen äh äh Organismen, äh die dann Vergiftungen hervorrufen, weil äh die Natur versucht halt ständig das fieseste, was sie sich ausde,
kann uns an Viren, Bakterien, Pilzen, Giften, Enzymen und so weiter entgegenzuwerfen, ja und uns keine Ahnung zu verflüssigen. Ähm so.
Und ähm insofern ja ist ist jetzt ich ich will jetzt damit nicht.
Wir sagen wir wir sollten jetzt äh also unbedingt.
Mit Gentechnik und so. Es ist jetzt der äh größte Lösung oder Atom äh Kraft oder so, aber will nur sagen ähm
wenn man jetzt gegen Atomkraft oder gegen Gentechnik ist, kann man vielleicht so ein bisschen nachvollziehen, warum andere Leute äh vielleicht
ja ähnliche Gefühle gegenüber äh Impfungen äh entwickeln, weil statistisch gesehen äh sehe ich da genau äh die selben Muster.
Eigentlich. Ja. Wie gesagt, das war auch in dem Zusammenhang, was ich meinte, so bisschen Nerd.
Position oder oder oder nördlich. Das ist halt schon ein bisschen eine eine nördliche Sicht, die halt einen Aspekt.
Einer Sache beleuchtet, ja? Und wo wo ich dann auch immer dazu schreibe, bitte äh versteht das nicht so, äh dass äh sagen, das ist jetzt nur ein Aspekt dieser Sache, aber natürlich mhm.
Verstehen die Leute dann wieder anderes und und es es artet dann in eine Debatte über das Pro und Contra von Atomkraft.
Aus, wo dann natürlich alle anderen Dinge dann äh mit mit reinkommen und
Das ist ja noch ganz in Ordnung, aber schlimmer ist dann, wenn ich dann plötzlich als Atomkraftbefürworter
äh äh äh weil wenn Leute das so lesen, dass ich jetzt Atomkraft befürworten würde. Dabei ist meine Position eigentlich nur die äh meine zur Atomkraft, okay.
Ähm Ausstieg ist okay, aber man hätte jetzt die schönen deutschen Atommeiler nicht so
zumachen müssen. Die hätten auch ein bisschen länger laufen können. Äh wenn man sich das nämlich anguckt, auch so äh sind
waren das die Geilsten äh äh Meiler überhaupt in Europa, mit denen am wenigsten schlimmen Störfällen, also was da alles unter um uns herum steht und betrieben wird.
Alles irgendwie viel gammliger und äh viel unzuverlässiger. Ja das ist sozusagen das Einzige, aber
grundsätzlich habe ich jetzt keine Probleme äh mit dem mit dem Atomausstieg. Wer wer halt noch nicht so,
gewesen, ja. Das war halt mehr so eine hysterische Überreaktion auf das Unglück von Fukushima. So ähm,
und ähm so das hätte man ein bisschen entspannter sehen können.
Und auch ja kommt zwar jetzt bisschen vom Thema ab aber einigen noch äh was mir auch äh mir fällt halt seitdem auch,
immer wieder auf, seit ich ein bisschen.
Ich gezwungen bin irgendwie alle Nachrichten etwas kritischer zu filtern oder irgendwie das zur durch durch Covid quasi zur Routine gemacht habe auch in anderen Bereichen ähnlich strikte,
Kriterien anzulegen mit irgendwie Quellen und und dann ich weiß nicht ob du's gesehen hast nach Fukushima gibt's halt jetzt auch,
gerade wieder aktuell, so wie sich denn die Wolke der Radioaktivität im
Pazifik ausbreitet, somit Farben von irgendwie blau bis schreiend rot und wie der ganze Pazifik jetzt radioaktiv verseucht ist so.
Fukushima mal zu.
Von Fukushima, genau. Guckt man ihm nachher, stellt man fest, okay, es handelt sich um eine Simulation und nicht um Messwerte. Okay und was
besagt in die Simulation, hm da stehen jetzt leider keine absoluten.
Werte, keine Radioaktivität oder Bäckerei-Werte dran. Gucken wir doch mal, äh ob's irgendwo Messwerte äh gibt
So und dann stellt man fest, nee, so richtig Messwerte gibt's nicht wirklich, aber es gibt halt Berechnungen, äh,
und äh dann stellt man fest, dass so ein Kubikmeter Meerwasser natürlich so also
ohne dass irgendwie jetzt Menschen irgendwas dazu getan haben, ungefähr 12000 Bäckerei pro Kubikmeter äh an Radioaktivität äh enthält. So
die Auswirkungen von Fukushima so im Pazifik ich sag mal in,
ab einer bestimmten Entfernung äh so ein, zweihundert Kilometer von Fukushima sind dann so in der Größenordnung, ich sage mal, zwischen ein,
und einhundert, ja. Bei einer natürlichen Belastung von zwölftausend, die das Meerwasser hat. So äh und.
Mit anderen Worten, äh das ist schlichtweg einfach nicht messbar. So passt da.
Irgendwie äh an Radioaktivitäts äh mengen ist und ich fühle mich dann äh immer äh eigentlich in die äh obwohl ich natürlich.
Das nicht
gut heiße, äh wenn irgendwie Radioaktivität freigesetzt wird oder überhaupt in den Pazifik gelangt und lokal sicherlich keine guten Auswirkungen äh hat und so und deswegen will ich eigentlich gar nicht in der Rolle,
befinden, irgendwie jetzt Atomkraft oder Gentechnik zu verteidigen, aber ähm ja, aber äh
Auf der anderen Seite äh wenn ich dann solche Verzerrungen oder Manipulationsversuche erkenne und wir werden dann vielleicht noch auf dann mal wieder auf einen,
im Zusammenhang mit OmiCronn kommen, der mir auch so ein bisschen übel aufgestoßen ist und auch wieder dann zu einer äh ja äh teilweise sehr heftigen Debatte auf,
geführt hat mit mit wilden äh äh Beschimpfungen so im Zusammenhang mit mit,
um Mikron, aber ich kann da nicht anders so äh als dann äh diese Rolle einzunehmen, ja.
Das ehrt dich ja auch und ich denke, dass wir in diesem Podcast schon immer auch so ein bisschen den Mut gehabt haben, äh einfach mal so ein paar Positionen auch einfach mal zu vertreten. Das heißt ja nicht, dass man auch immer derselben Meinung bleiben muss.
Ich würde gerne so ein bisschen zu deinem Kernargument zurückkommen, was ja im Wesentlichen war
haben manchmal auch andere Sichtweisen und sie sind vielleicht nicht generell als Vollidioten abzustempeln oder das auch nicht unbedingt produktiv das zu tun, um sie letzten Endes mit in diesen
wie soll ich sagen, Wunschkonsens mit reinzubringen, das ist doch eigentlich eine ganz geile Idee wäre, wenn wir jetzt mal
90 Prozent aller Leute impfen würden, weil es würde uns mal echt weiterhelfen und im Übrigen auch ihre eigenen Interessen
fördern auch wenn sie eigentlich genau das Gegenteil davon annehmen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Problem, dass man so ein bisschen den Eindruck hat, dass sie eigentlich so gegen
Also sie wollen zwar was, so Freiheit und äh keine Einschränkungen mehr und keine Masken tragen und was weiß ich, nicht noch alles.
Ähm nur dass ihre Vorstellung darüber, wie man an dieses Ziel kommt, halt sich extrem unterscheidet von dem, was so die Mehrheit der Leute eigentlich so denkt.
Ja und ähm ich meine gut manche Leute es ist wirklich schwierig äh sie zu.
Überzeugen von von irgendetwas, aber die beste Chance hat man,
aus meiner Sicht, wenn man sie erstmal da abholt, äh wo sie gerade stehen, wenn man erstmal versucht so ein bisschen zu begreifen äh äh eigentlich, was denn die tatsächlich die Mechanismen
äh sind und äh auch zu verstehen, äh wie man vielleicht selber auch äh in der Rolle hätte landen können. Ähm.
Auch mal gelandet ist.
Ja oder mal in anderen Zusammenhängen mal gelandet ist, wo man plötzlich äh ich sage mal extreme Positionen eingenommen hat in irgendeiner Sache, was es sich beim Datenschutz,
oder so, um jetzt so ein Nerd.
Ja gutes Beispiel.
Zu liefern, ja, wo äh ich sage mal auch äh sagen im im
Chaos, Computerclub, ich auch äh oder oder selbst unter Datenschützern. Ich äh äh den einen oder anderen ja als Datenschutzextremisten bezeichnen äh würde. Der äh ja wo wo im Endeffekt,
äh mehr gesellschaftlicher Schaden als nutzen äh äh von äh entsteht. Ja
äh aber äh klar, das äh da gibt es nun mal verschiedene Sichtweisen und und Bewertungen oder
in der Piraten-Partei der der Kampf zwischen Transparenz und Privatsphäre als Politiker, ja.
Oder als ich sage mal dann im Zusammenhang mit Liquid Democracy, wo halt irgendwie alle einerseits Politiker sind, aber andererseits eben auch Nicht-Politiker und äh wie viel äh Transparenz äh soll jetzt herrschen darüber, wer
sagen, also auf der einen Seite wer welche politische Meinung vertritt, also sprich wie viel
sollen sich die Leute dann rechtfertigen müssen oder äh inwieweit dürfen sie einfach anonym bleiben und die Grenzen natürlich fließend und das waren auch die heftigsten Auseinandersetzungen, die ich erlebt habe, war natürlich die Einrichtung Transparenz gegangen sind und gesagt haben, nee
so das ist sonst nicht nachvollziehbar, das sind sonst geheime Wahlen, sonst können wir es überhaupt nicht machen öffnet halt Manipulation Tür und Tor und.
Pablo jetzt musst du aber auch auf den Punkt äh zurückkommen, von dem er ausgestattet sind, nämlich so Impfpflicht und wie ähm gehen wir denn sozusagen jetzt mit den Leuten um, die das jetzt äh erst mal betrifft? Weil sie sich noch nicht haben impfen lassen.
Ja ähm ja.
Ihr so praktisch veranlagt bin bei Pod.
Nee ich meine leider sind natürlich jetzt die die Fronten äh schon so verfestigt und man hätte da vermutlich äh äh früher Ansätzen müssen
aber ähm ja ich denke da ist auch äh also Hopfen und Malz äh sind da auch nicht verloren so.
Und äh man kann zum Beispiel eine äh Sache, die mir dann eingefallen ist, warum eigentlich auch nicht das Angebot an Impfstoffen
äh verbreitern. Also ich sage mal auch zu sagen okay, wenn die Leute, dann weiß ich nicht, sich einen chinesischen oder einen russischen
Impfstoff äh impfen lassen wollen. Ich meine in den Ländern
die haben halt auch kein Interesse daran, ihre Bevölkerung krank zu machen oder unwirksame Impfstoffe äh zu verimpfen und da liegen halt auch Zahlen vor und die kann man sich eigentlich auch angucken.
Und äh dann äh was weiß ich, ja äh da hat man dann schon die Hälfte der Leute wahrscheinlich wieder lassen sich da lassen sich damit äh meinetwegen mit einem äh äh russischen oder chinesischen oder kubanischen
Impfstoff impfen, wenn sie halt den westlichen
Großkonzernen nicht trauen. Ich meine, da fällt einem auch kein Zacken äh äh aus der Krone. Ähm oder wie siehst du das?
Na gut, ich meine äh es ist viel, wenn man hätte dies tun müssen, man hätte das äh lassen müssen. Das steht ja auch alles außer Frage. Nur jetzt sind wir.
Punkt angekommen.
Sind Dinge, die man aber noch machen kann, ja.
Genau, also man müsste jetzt eben schauen wie wie geht man jetzt ran und ich denke, es muss halt.
Alles getan werden. Auf der einen Seite die Impfpflicht, einfach auch um mal klarzustellen, auch rechtlich mal klarzustellen, so nach dem Motto, okay, jetzt ist es nicht mehr freie Entscheidung, sondern jetzt.
Wollen wir das von unseren Bürgern? Weil sich viele ja auch einfach so raus äh reden. Ich hatte auch irgendwie so ein.
Nachbarn im Flur und hat grad irgendwie Buserimpfungstermintipps äh am Start und fragst du nach der wie ist es bei euch hier mit Boostern? So ja ich bin ja noch gar nicht geimpft. Ich so bitte was?
Ja, ja, ja. So äh hallo, ähm guck mal auf die Uhr ist irgendwie November zwanzig einundzwanzig. Also wir haben, ist ja eine persönliche Entscheidung.
Aha ist ist keine persönliche äh Entscheidung mehr. Also die Zeiten, wo das eine persönliche Entscheidung war.
Vorbei. So, das Gespräch ging natürlich dann nicht äh sehr viel weiter, wie du dir vorstellen kannst. Hat auch keinen jetzt Bock, das irgendwie so im ähm en-Passon im im Flur aus zu diskutieren. Nur,
Einerseits habe ich halt gemerkt, es gibt Leute, die brauchen noch irgendwie ganz andere Überzeugungen und da ist dann halt einfach so ein
Impfpflicht ist jetzt einfach mal angesagt, ja ähm dreht schon mal die ganze Argumentationskette um.
Mhm, ja, aber ähm also was ich in solchen Situationen, ich hatte auch ähm
kenne auch ein paar Ungeimpfte, auch die alles andere als dumm sind äh so und alles andere als ja eigentlich würde ich sagen impfskeptisch, also habe
Also viele Leute äh haben da äh äh gesagt so also meine Reaktion war dann eher so äh ja warum, was sind denn sozusagen für euch eigentlich die Gründe
die ihr seht, was euch denn davon abhält und viele Leute sagen dann, ey, ich habe ein volles Impfbuch, ja, ich habe mich gegen irgendwie bisher gegen alles impfen lassen, aber diese,
mRNA Impfstoffe, die sind mir einfach unheimlich und wenn es irgendwie einen Impfstoff gäbe oder oder auch die Vektor-Impfstoffe oder so. Das ist mir äh ja so vom Gefühl her, ja ist mir das
äh noch zu unheimlich. Da habe ich irgendwie zu viel beunruhigende.
Dinge äh gesehen. Na ja gut, das dringt irgendwie in meine Zellen ein und mache da irgendwie Dinge dann in den äh Zellen und und so und sagten, wenn ich einen normalen.
Wie alle anderen Impfstoffe auch.
Ja äh aber dann sagen die Leute, wenn ich irgendwie einen normalen, weiß ich nicht, Protein-Impfstoff oder irgendwie ein abgeschwächtes Virus, wie äh ich das früher äh so mit all meinen anderen Impfungen gekriegt
dann würde ich mich auch impfen lassen, dann hätte ich die Bedenken nicht. Aber das ist mir zu neumodisch
ja und ich weiß nicht, ich ich finde, das ist jetzt auch nichts also wo man jetzt zumindest das Denken oder das grundsätzliche Misstrauen gegenüber,
neuen Technologien ist,
auch nicht völlig unbegründet, ja. Also wir haben alle irgendwie Dinge äh erfahren, wo dann sagen äh Dinge, die dann
dann gehypt äh wurden, ähm sich dann plötzlich als gefährlich oder giftig herausgestellt äh haben. Ja ähm,
Insofern ja, ich meine nicht, dass das gerechtfertigt wäre jetzt, aber so ist nun mal dann äh die die
Wahrnehmung so und wir haben nun mal kognitive Systeme, die auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise funktionieren und da kann man jetzt nicht Leuten sagen irgendwie okay äh jetzt äh lass mal deinen.
Ja du dein kognitives System ist Scheiße und du bist doof, ja? Äh sondern äh da muss man halt schon gucken, okay äh.
Wo liegt denn das Problem und wie kann man die Leute dann da raus manövrieren und das ist halt sehr individuell äh äh verschieden und auch nicht äh irgendwie,
nicht nicht 100 Prozent sicher und ähm.
Ja äh ich sehe den ich sehe den Punkt so, ja und solche Fälle gibt es.
Aber die Zahl der Leute, bei denen das so alles so zusammenkommt, ist so überschaubar, die kannst du am Ende auch einfach ungeimpft lassen.
Bescheinigen, hat ein Beratungsgespräch äh äh geführt und irgendwie.
Wurden dann alle Optionen äh dargelegt und äh die Impfpflicht wird äh um drei Monate verschoben wegen neuer Impfstoff wird erwartet.
Ja, das ist das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das äh irgend.
Dass wir ein flexibler Umgang mit so einer Impfpflicht. Ich sage ja auch nicht und deswegen vermeide ich auch in dieser Debatte gerne diesen Begriff Impfzwang.
Ja, auch wenn ich sehe, das ist ja auch in den Kommentaren angemerkt worden, äh zur letzten Sendung. So, dass da natürlich ist eine Pflicht, irgendwann auch zwangsläufig einen Zwang, weil deswegen ist es ja Pflicht. Ja? So, aber wir sagen ja auch Gurtpflicht und nicht Gurtzwang.
Und gibt immer Leute, die sich nicht anschnallen, aber wir haben's schon irgendwie hinbekommen über eine Gurtpflicht dazu zu.
Dass wir im Verkehr schon im Wesentlichen eigentlich alle angeschnallt sind. Auch wenn's immer noch Leute gibt, die's nicht sind. Aber das eigentliche Problem, Verkehrstote zu äh reduzieren, hat durchaus funktioniert, auch wenn sie am Anfang alle genauso geschrien haben wie ähm jetzt bei der Impfung auch.
Ja und äh also Impfpflichten und Impfpflichten funktionieren in dem Sinne auch äh so, aber
Äh sie sind halt ich sage mal auch wiederum Staatstheoretisch äh nicht so optimal oder effektiv, weil sie halt hohe Kontroll- und Erzwingungskosten äh haben, ja. Ähm und das ist halt dann also ja
äh suboptimal und es ist halt auch ja äh keine moderne äh,
Regierungskunst äh sage ich mal damit zu operieren. Ähm ist halt ein bisschen archaisch. Ja ähm aber das heißt nicht, dass es nicht trotzdem funktioniert und ähm ja.
Ja, aber so haben wir alle Sicherheitssysteme äh durchgesetzt bekommen. So und ich meine, wir haben jetzt ähm wie viel Millionen, warte mal,
World in Data sagt, es sind jetzt geimpft worden.
So das ist natürlich alles so ein bisschen ähm so eine Sache, aber wir haben jetzt irgendwie.
Über vier Milliarden Personen geimpft. Auf diesem Plan.
Weltweit. Mhm.
Weltweit so. Also mehr als 50 Prozent. Wir sind irgendwie bei.
55 Prozent. Und es ist.
Nichts passiert. Ja, klar, es gab hier ein paar Komplikationen und da ein paar Kombinationen von Impfstoffen und Alter und einzelnen Personen und so weiter klar aber nichts, was auch nur ansatzweise ähm den Komplikationen.
Entspricht, die die Krankheit als solche mit sich bringt. Das ist jetzt klar, dass das sicher ist.
Genau und das erklären wir, das erkläre ich den oder das versuche ich den Leuten dann auch immer zu erklären als
sagen ultimatives äh ad hoc Argument so okay und wenn,
des Zeugs ist milliardenfach verimpft worden und äh wenn das wirklich gefährlich äh wäre, wäre das jetzt schon aufgefallen, aber dann kommt natürlich,
das berühmte Argument mit den Langzeitfolgen, dass man auch nicht wissen könnte ähm.
Wie das mit den Langzeitfolgen äh aussieht, äh wobei wir, klar, dann die Standardentgegnung äh sagen von uns oder von mir äh war und ist
ist auch äh bis bisher das eigentlich der ja das aber der Impfstoff innerhalb von
äh Tagen oder zumindest nach Wochen äh einfach weg ist und sich auflöst und sagen Folgen, die sich bis dahin äh nicht nicht eingestellt haben so innerhalb von
vier bis sechs äh Wochen äh nach der Impfung. Da gibt es jetzt auch keinen wirklichen Wirkmechanismus äh warum sich danach noch Folgen einstellen sollten.
Ich sage jetzt immer, fragt Joschi Joschua Kimmich nach den Langzeitfolgen.
Äh ja von äh genau von äh ja äh und das Virus hat natürlich äh noch deutlich, deutlich krassere äh Langzeitfolgen äh das wissen wir.
Aber in der Argumentation äh mit den Leuten äh ist das äh nicht.
Entspricht es nicht irgendwie die Leute da abzuholen äh wo sie gerade sind äh sondern das ist dann auch wieder eher aber hier äh so.
Nee ähm so und ähm was.
Dann eher jetzt mein Ansatz ist oder war, ich weiß auch nicht, ob der ob der jetzt besser oder oder schlechter ist, aber äh sagen ja.
Ähm es gibt durchaus denkbare Wirkmechanismen, die Schäden äh wo Schäden.
Nach Jahren oder im Alter oder äh in der nächsten Generation auftreten können.
Ja. Äh theoretisch äh äh ist es, ist es durchaus möglich so. Also beispielsweise über eben dann Epigenetik. Aber.
Dass das passiert äh ist einfach ähm ja.
Extrem, extrem, extrem unwahrscheinlich äh so. Also es gibt keine äh keine Gründe dafür, so.
Warum das passieren äh sollte und.
Ähm ich weiß nicht, der und dann war die Reaktion, dass die Leute sich also erstmal schon mal ernst genommen fühlen, dass man sagt, sie sind halt schon mal keine kompletten
Vollpfosten, sondern wir sind dann halt äh schon mal bei der Debatte nur sagen, okay äh in meinem,
wie wahrscheinlich ist denn das so im im Vergleich zu jetzt anderen Risiken oder Gefahrenen, dann ist man am Reden ja und nicht am sich gegenseitig versuchen äh zu überzeugen
ähm so was erstmal nicht funktioniert, sondern erstmal ja Verständnis für den anderen, für den Standpunkt des anderen zu entwickeln und sagen,
Kommunikation herzustellen, dann kann man auch beginnen äh erst äh sagen ähm ja.
Einfluss auf die Meinung der Leute äh äh zu nehmen, finde ich äh und selbst das, ja, klappt natürlich nicht nicht immer und ist halt kann halt sehr mühsam sein.
Und frustrierend.
Ja, also wie man's dreht und wendet, äh irgendwas muss jetzt getan werden und ähm ich denke, man sollte alles Mögliche tun. Man sollte einfach die Impfung so
niedrigschwellig anbieten, wie's nur irgendwie geht. Man muss natürlich auf die Leute zugehen, man muss mehr Aufklärungsinformationspotential äh entwickeln.
Aktiv das Ganze machen, Terminbuchung so einfach wie möglich realisieren
vorausschauend handeln und nicht immer drauf hoffen vor allem, was glaube ich so ein bisschen das Hauptproblem war, dass das Problem schon irgendwie von alleine wieder weggehen wird und was halt äh diese Überzeugungsarbeit betrifft.
Ich sehe viele äh Punkte, die du da hast, so stimmt so. Es gibt so einzelne Leute, aber ich mir kann einfach keiner erzählen,
der Großteil der Leute nicht diese ganzen Diskussionen vor allem deshalb führt weil sie irgendwie einfach grundsätzlich einfach,
dagegen sein wollen, zu faul sind oder nicht bereit sind, sich da ausreichend Gedanken darüber zu machen oder auch einfach nicht genug Verantwortung,
Bewusstsein haben, um einfach da sozusagen für die Gesellschaft was zu tun, sondern es einfach immer nur aus so einem und was habe ich davon, äh Position heraus zu machen? Und für die Leute ist halt.
Diese Pflicht gedacht. So und ähm.
Deswegen bin ich da auch äh ganz klar ein äh Verfechter davon. Ich finde es auch nicht unbedingt toll,
dass es soweit kommen musste, aber ich denke, dass es jetzt einfach der Punkt ist erreicht,
Ist einfach sinnlos ist, weiter darüber nachzudenken.
Wie man jetzt dieses Argument noch von links nach rechts drehen kann oder was man hier vielleicht noch für eine Überzeugungsfinte machen kann. Das ist jetzt einfach alles ein anderthalb Jahre rum. Es war jetzt genug Zeit und wer jetzt der Meinung ist, er hat von dieser Pandemie noch nichts äh gehört oder verstanden.
Sorry, den muss man halt auch einfach nur noch sagen, was zu tun ist und nicht irgendwie noch in irgendwelche.
Einsteigen mit so einer unterinformiertheit, die äh aus Internetforen herausgeboren ist.
Wie gesagt, ich ich also vor ein paar Wochen so hätte ich dir ja noch noch voll beigepflichtet, aber ähm ich sehe das äh.
Ja jetzt jetzt schon auch aus ein bisschen anderen äh Blickwinkel. Ähm.
Es ist ja nicht also sagst jetzt okay das ist jetzt egoistisch äh was was die Leute dort tun ähm.
Aber ähm ja es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute
dort wirklich irgendetwas tun, sondern sie wollen halt irgendetwas einfach nicht tun und das ist schon mal
ja es kann natürlich auch äh Egoismus äh sein, aber sie kommen halt einfach zu einer anderen Bewertung von Fakten oder
Sie haben äh eine falsche oder selektive Auswahl von Fakten. Ja das sind so die die zwei.
Dinge, ja aber es ist ja ja ähm also ich ich werfe das den Leuten äh nicht.
Persönlich vor.
Oh nein, das mache ich auch nicht. Ich will einfach nur, dass sie sich impfen lassen. Fertig.
Ansonsten ist mir das egal. Die können auch danach auch sofort wieder glauben, was sie wollen. Machen sie dann sowieso, aber ähm bei der Impferei ist halt irgendwie einfach jetzt die Diskussion zu Ende.
Einfach zu Ende diskutiert.
Müssen das jetzt auch nicht auflösen. Wir können wir können das an dieser Stelle auch mal so als offenen Disput ähm äh im Raum stehen lassen, weil ich glaube das repräsentiert dann sozusagen auch,
ganz gut wie das allgemein äh auch an anderen Stellen diskutiert wird und ähm ja so ist es halt einfach.
Aber wir müssen jetzt doch langsam mal so ein bisschen zu den eigentlichen Breaking News kommen. Nämlich zu äh OmiCronn.
O-Mikro und Omicro, ein Omicron, haben wir ja letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen, dass es äh da ist. Habt ihr jetzt auch schon alle schon mal gehört. Wahrscheinlich sind auch schon alle Wortwitze damit gemacht worden. Von daher ersparen wir euch das. Ähm.
Ich habe gar keine äh äh gar keine gehört. Jetzt muss jetzt musst du äh doch äh ein paar erzählen, weil weil.
Ach so, ja, nee, nee, das gibt's dann im Bonustrack irgendwie und ähm.
Äh okay, ich ich kannte nur halt Delta Airways zum Beispiel, aber bei OmiCronn habe ich jetzt äh.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht in solchen Sachen verfangen. Ich will jetzt einfach mal über die Sache reden. Ähm also, wir haben
in dieser Woche mal wieder so ein etwas ähm belebteren Informationsfluss gehabt, so würde ich das mal nennen, so ein bisschen ähm wie wir das jetzt hier eigentlich schon längere Zeit vermisst haben, was so unseren eigentlichen
Antrieb für diesen Podcast betrifft, dass ähm noch nicht alles klar ist, aber es sickern halt jetzt so so Daten durch, ne. Der ganze
ähm Omicron, die ganze Omicron-Geschichte ist jetzt grad mal ein Monat her. Das heißt, man weiß jetzt, aha, okay, neue Variante, sie wurde jetzt schon analysiert, sie wurde jetzt getestet. Man hat halt festgestellt, so aha okay hier gegen Antikörper.
Das alles deutlich weniger. Auch Sandra Ziesek hat äh glaube ich so eine Untersuchung gemacht.
Und alle kommen so ein bisschen äh auf den Punkt so, aha okay, super äh infektiös. Auf der einen Seite, ja, also man sieht das in Südafrika, gehen die Zahlen nach oben, extrem, noch stärker als bei Delta.
Also super den das Ding hat also super R0Wert den das Ding hat.
Ähm auf der anderen Seite, wie übrigens auch schon wir das mit Beta äh hatten, ja, reduzierte Reaktionen auf.
Antikörper, die von Impfstoffen äh gebildet wurden. Also wenn jemand
ist, dann äh nimmt man halt die Antikörper aus dem Blut, setzt sie gegen dieses Virus an und guckt mal, wie gut das so bekämpft wird und dann hat man halt äh mit so und so viel Probanden macht man das so durch und dann,
halt wie gut äh wirkt das und das ging dann halt so. Je nachdem, wem man jetzt ähm zitiert, habe ich irgendwas von,
Faktor 17 bis Faktor 41, so in dem Bereich gelesen. Sprich,
die eigentliche Antikörper Reaktion, also die unmittelbare Sofortbekämpfung äh des Körpers, die ist halt reduziert. Jetzt war das eben auch schon bei Beta ja das der große Aufschrei, als er irgendwie so Faktor sieben attestiert wurde.
Ähm klar war auch ein Problem, gerade in Südafrika, wo Beta gut durchgerauscht ist. Uns hat das nicht so sehr betroffen, weil wir dann schon von ähm
Alpha noch genug äh zu tun hatten und das dann später von Delta übernommen wurde. Aber ähm.
Die Botschaft war halt auch immer klar, die Impfstoffe wirken letzten Endes ja nicht nur in der unmittelbaren Antikörperreaktion, sondern
der eigentliche Schutz ist der Schutz vor schwerer Erkrankung und vor Tod und der spielt sich natürlich dann vor allem im
Teezellenbereich ab, also die Killerzellen, die ja letzten Endes gegen infizierte Zellen vorgehen und dann eben sozusagen als zweite oder dritte Verteidigungslinie im Körper den eigentlichen Schutz vor wirklich schweren Verläufen darstellt und das ist
derzeit noch total unklar. Das weiß man einfach noch nicht, wie sich das mit Omicron so verhält.
Genau und ich habe mich
gesagt vor zwei Tagen so bei manchen Leuten bisschen dadurch unbeliebt äh gemacht. Ähm so indem ich halt diese ähm ja Studie äh von Sandra,
Zieseck ähm so ähm kommentiert habe mit einem kurzen und knappen Tweet, weil,
sie hat als sie dann irgendwas von den Faktoren geschrieben hat und so, also ich musste mich dann erstmal ja mehrere Minuten äh wirklich mit dem mit dem Bild beschäftigen, um jetzt zu verstehen, so was denn da jetzt
eigentlich, was das denn jetzt irgendwie bedeutet so. Und irgendwann.
Also das Bild, was so rumgetwittert wurde mit ihren Messzahlen.
Rumgetwittert wurde, genau mit den verschiedenen
Daten äh aus aus Neutralisationstests äh also wie äh stark bestimmte
Antikörper äh wirken im im Labor, in welcher Konzentration gegen welchen Varianten,
also welch wer schafft es sich dann noch zu vermehren in der Zellkultur und welch welcher nicht so bei welcher Konzentration und ähm,
Ja, äh das ist natürlich nicht identisch mit äh wirklich Ansteckungsschutz. Da muss man dann irgendwie sicherlich äh nochmal, also sind die,
aber es ist halt schon indikativ, weil man macht die Tests ja auch nie aus Spaß so, sondern die äh lassen schon eine gewisse Aussage darüber zu äh wie sich denn der relative Schutz verhält. So und nachdem ich mir das halt,
bisschen angeguckt habe. Äh so habe ich dann das kommentiert mit, das sieht nicht gut aus. Auf den Punkt gebracht,
die aktuellen Impfungen schützen praktisch nicht vor Ansteckung mit OmiCron, auch mit Booster nicht. Cobra übernehmen sie. So, das war.
Das war halt äh mein Tweet, weil ich wollte da jetzt auch äh sagen eigentlich nur,
vielleicht anderen Leuten ersparen äh oder ja äh fünf Minuten auf dieses Bild zu gucken und dann immer noch nicht zu wissen, was jetzt mit diesen Faktoren
äh so, aber es läuft wie gesagt auf den Punkt raus, schützen praktisch nicht vor Ansteckung mit OmiCron,
auch mit Booster nicht, ja und mit Schützen praktisch,
so äh meine ich, dass sie irgendwie einen Schutzfaktor.
Am Anfang vielleicht von 1,5 bis 2 vor Ansteckung. Vielleicht kann man irgendwie noch vier oder so da reininterpretieren, aber nee, eigentlich nicht.
Äh eigentlich eher zwischen eins und eins ,fünf. So und wenn man dann noch
mit einbezieht das äh das Geimpfte sich unvorsichtiger verhalten als Ungeimpfte. Was man auch statistisch sieht, kann das ganz schnell dazu führen, dass äh,
bei Geimpften äh sich das Ganze äh umdreht, wenn die biologische Wirkung nicht da ist, dass sozusagen dann plötzlich
Geimpfte häufiger erkranken als äh Ungeimpfte, weil sie sich unvorsichtiger verhalten. Ja ähm.
Und äh da sind wir noch nicht. Da sind wir noch lange, weil weil im Moment ist halt bei uns Delta noch unterwegs. Ich habe
äh äh gerade vorhin auch die aktuellen Zahlen vom vom RKI aus deren Variantenmonitoring äh geholt und.
Ähm in also
zwei Wochen, also in vor drei Wochen in KW 48 hatten wir den ersten nachgewiesenen, umikron Fall in äh Deutschland in der Folgewoche waren's dann 16 Fälle
und in der letzten Woche waren's vierundvierzig Fälle. Also.
Ähm wurde erst versechzehnfacht, aber klar, das ist halt ungenau und dann
sich fast verdreifacht innerhalb von einer Woche die Zahl der Fälle. Ist jetzt noch keine gute statistische Basis, aber
Aus anderen Ländern wissen wir, äh dass äh OmiCronnen,
geht äh wie nix anderes, also wie äh kein anderes, keine andere Variante äh zuvor, also es heißt äh viele Leute gehen davon aus, dass es ungefähr doppelt so ansteckend ist, aber.
Kommt natürlich auch mal drauf an, unter welchen Bedingungen und äh ja und welchen Temperatur und Luftfeuchte Verhältnissen und so gibt's da Unterschiede und.
Ähm ja ähm das äh.
Wie gesagt, das und diese dieses dieser Punkt oder das ist einfach auf den Punkt zu bringen. Ich habe jetzt nur gesagt.
Aktuellen Impfungen schützen praktisch nicht vor Ansteckung mit OmiCrott. Es wurde dann jetzt dann massiv dafür angegangen, dass ich nicht erwähnt habe, dass es äh nur für die Ansteckung und nicht für den Langzeit
Schutz gilt, dass der ja dann trotzdem noch äh oder nein, dass darüber gar keine Aussagen getroffen
werden können aufgrund dessen.
Hast du ja auch nicht gemacht.
Nö, habe ich ja auch nicht gemacht, aber ich wurde dafür kritisiert, dass ich das nicht äh sozusagen, dass ich das nicht noch dazu gesagt.
Habe, dass ich quasi das dazu hätte sagen müssen und das ist deswegen unverantwortlich sei und ich den Eindruck erwecken würde sagen Booster äh helfen nicht und man bräuchte sich jetzt nicht Boostern äh zu lassen. So.
Auch außer gleich wieder eine Kanzel äh Action bekommen dafür.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Äh nee, aber ich habe dann äh habe ich wie gesagt darüber nachgedacht
denn das überhaupt stimmt sozusagen ob dieser Disclaimer den ich da hätte bringen müssen äh dass es keine Aussage zulässt über das Risiko
Ähm äh so jetzt eines schweren Verlaufs äh wie es war und das ist sachlich falsch.
Auch noch, ja. Das heißt, ich oder dafür kritisiert, dass ich nicht etwas Falsches äh sozusagen dazu gesagt habe und es ist deswegen falsch, weil natürlich nach ich sage mal Wahrscheinlichkeit, ich hatte ja vorhin deswegen dann schon
Auseinanderrechnen von Ansteckungsschutz und dann, wenn man erstmal angesteckt ist, den Schutz bevor ja Intensivstationen oder Hospitalisierung äh oder oder Tod.
Und ähm wir gehen halt von dem Gesamtschutz aus sozusagen als äh sagen welchen Schutz bietet mir die Impfung.
Gegenüber äh der Variante vor Tod. Dann ist das ein zusammengesetzter Schutz aus dem Schutz vor Ansteckung und diesem langfristigen, ich sage mal, T-Zellenschutz, ja und wenn aber die
erste äh sagen die die erste Brandmauer äh oder die der erste Schutzwall irgendwo wegfällt
und äh auf einmal nicht mehr da ist, wenn man sagen äh der Gegner den Schlüssel hat so
für den für die für die erste Tür.
Ähm ja dann steigt natürlich auch meine Gefahr äh zu Schaden äh zu kommen und zwar äh gewaltig, weil wie wir vorhin gesehen.
Äh haben so bei dieser Auseinanderrechnung,
aktuell der größte Schutzfaktor, also 74 Prozent oder 3,85 ist äh aktuell der Schutz vor Infektionen.
Gegen Delta und dann bleibt eben noch einen Schutz von ja eins Komma neun bis zwei Komma sieben sieben, je nachdem, also Intensivstation ist zwei Komma sieben sieben tot zwei Komma eins acht und Krankenhaus eins Komma acht neun.
Ja dann bleibt mir also von meinen ursprünglich rund 90 Prozent Schutz gegen,
Tod bleiben mir plötzlich nur noch 50 oder 60 Prozent
übrig. So, das heißt, es erlaubt also schon äh erstmal eine
Aussage äh äh darüber, nämlich die äh dass es sehr wahrscheinlich ist, äh ja, dass dass die Gefahr dass dadurch die Gefahr.
Vor ähm ja tot oder schwer im Verlauf äh äh höher ist bei OmiCron, ja.
Also das ist jetzt auch noch nicht gesagt, dass es so ist, aber man kann auf jeden Fall nicht sagen, dass es äh auf jeden Fall nicht so ist. Und ähm von daher äh hast du natürlich Recht und man muss auch sehen
höhere Ansteckung hat ja auch einen also die höhere Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeit die man jetzt sieht
Also ne, es frisst sich ja durch äh Südafrika durch und sagen auch gleich noch mal spezifisch was zur äh Südafrika-Situation, aber äh die hohen Inzidenzen, die dort sind, die sprechen ja eben klar dafür, dass eben dieser A null sehr viel höher ist, also dass quasi
Grundansteckungsfähigkeit dieses Virus, dieser Virusvariante eben noch mal sehr viel höher ist als die anderen Varianten, die wir bisher gesehen haben.
Und das damit das passiert, muss ja dieses Virus eine bestimmte Eigenschaft haben und.
Es könnte besser durch Aerosole fliegen, aber das ist auch glaube ich eher unwahrscheinlich, weil schon jetzt geht man davon aus,
Delta äh quasi so in Tröpfchen, die gerade mal so groß genug sind, um überhaupt einen einzigen Virus zu tragen äh schon durch die Gegend fliegen können. Also hat zwar meistens was mit äh höherer Replikationsfähigkeit zu tun.
Bedeutet höhere Viruslast und das bedeutet natürlich, dass dann eben der Körper auch automatisch bei einer Ansteckung auch mit mehr Virus ähm
im Mittel äh befallen wird und dann kommen natürlich andere Faktoren mit rein, nämlich wie,
Oder wie gefährlich ist jetzt diese Variante eben tatsächlich für den Körper? Das wissen wir eben in dem Sinne noch nicht.
Und all das Ganze muss erstmal beobachtet und ausgerechnet werden bevor man dafür eine abschließende Aussage oder überhaupt auch erstmal nur eine andeutende Aussage treffen kann.
Ja und da gibt es eben auch verschiedene Theorien stehen da jetzt im Raum. Die eine äh es bestätigen zumindest auch äh so
jetzt molekulare Simulationen ist, dass das Spike-Protein
von OmiCron einfach äh besser in die entsprechenden äh Rezeptoren äh hineinpasst. Das heißt, man kann sich das so vorstellen, äh dass.
Die Spikes ein bisschen magnetischer sind, also leichter irgendwie ins Schloss passen und dass
äh das Material dann auch noch leichter ähm irgendwie reingleitet, dass sich irgendwie dann auch der Mechanismus, der dann entsprechend äh ja ähm
die.
Zelle äh aufschließt äh für für das für das Virusmaterial. Das ist halt einfach besser flutscht in die Zelle reinflutscht, könnte man sagen, dass das Virus, also ohne. Und.
Ähm und da und
was welche Folgen das jetzt fürs Krankmachen hat, äh ja, da gibt's dann jetzt völlig entgegenlaufende Thesen. Die eine geht in die Richtung, die sagt, na ja, weil's halt irgendwie so besser flutscht, geht das halt auch alles schneller und äh wird daher es daher auch potenziell heftiger.
Äh eher, ist also heftige, krank machend. Ähm.
Wir scheinen das bei ungeimpften jungen Leuten zumindest zu sehen. Also da gibt es Hinweise darauf. So auf der anderen Seite
scheint es aber dann wiederum ähm äh könnte es auch sein, weil es ist da bestimmte hm,
Sequenzen gibt, die aus einem anderen Herzschnupfen oder Erkältungs-Corona-Virus stammen beziehungsweise äh sich auch im
äh menschlichen Erbgut wiederfinden, dass man sagen, okay, das ist halt jetzt besser angepasst. Es flutscht halt jetzt irgendwie besser und macht halt deswegen dann auch nicht so viel kaputt.
Äh einfach einfacher gesagt, dass es halt,
von einem sagen besser angepassteren äh äh Virus äh irgendwie stammt. Wir wissen es noch nicht. Es sind beides irgendwo Vermutungen äh und es könnte auch beides so ein bisschen wahr sein und
Könnte halt schon auch sein, dass äh tatsächlich bei äh Geimpften äh dann auch mit dem anderen Vaxin äh Geimpften dann äh trotzdem.
Die äh Schutzwirkung äh durch die durch die T-Zellen genauso groß ist und da wäre quasi der Mechanismus dahinter, weil äh sagen das die T-Zellen nicht,
unterscheiden zwischen Zellen, die mit äh Omi-Kron und die mit einer anderen Variante äh befallen werden. Das ist sozusagen der, der Schutz
in dem Fall dass der Schutz quasi äh den den Schutz gegen beide Varianten beinhaltet, weil da die TCL nicht so selektiv
sind.
Steht im Raum, dass dass also
Das Muster für die die T-Zellen sich bisher angepasst haben bei den derzeitigen Impfstoffen im Vergleich zu dem Muster, was jetzt bei äh Omicorn äh äh letzten Endes auf der Ebene sichtbar wird.
Ne, das ist eine andere Ebene als die Antikörper-Reaktion, dass das so bei 80 Prozent liegt. Also das ist ungefähr so 80 Prozent von dem sichtbar ist, ähm was ähm vorher sichtbar war und dass man von daher davon ausgeht, dass die Zielzellen
schon noch genug Erkennungsfläche haben, um sich aktivieren zu können.
Ja äh sprich wenn also wenn das sich jetzt als zutreffend herausstellt man sagen ist es wahrscheinlich auch eine etwas
geringere, also eine leicht geringere Schutzwirkung äh äh dann äh gegen wenn man sich erst mal äh infiziert hat. Was ich für.
Plausibel halte und wo man äh im Moment bis halt äh weitere genauere Zahlen man äh äh vorliegen, man davon ausgehen könnte, dass es sollte. Das ist dann in etwa
äh ja genauso oder.
Leicht schlechter äh diesen Langzeitschutz hat, wenn man sich erst mal infiziert hat. Was aber bad News ist. So was aber ganz klar Bad News ist.
So, aber äh nicht so, dass man soll sich jetzt nicht boostern lassen, aber es ist nichtsdestotrotz really really bad news und.
Ich glaube, dass es vielen Leuten halt äh nicht nicht so klar.
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus? Also vielleicht sollten wir erstmal.
Okay, worauf ich hinaus will ist, das war dann man prompt am nächsten Tag nach dem Sweat äh kam dann halt äh einen,
Artikel im Tagesspiegel, äh den ich dann, wo ich dann äh nur kommentiert habe, diesmal genau anders.
Alle zeigten leichte Symptome, erkrankten aber nicht schwer. Unter sieben Deutsche infizieren sich in Südafrika trotz Drittinfung, ja.
So und
Ist halt eine Gruppe von 7 Deutschen im Alter von 25 bis 39 Jahren hat sich in der in Südafrika mit der OmiCron-Variante des coronavirus infiziert, obwohl alle bereits ihre Boosterimpfung erhalten haben, so.
Ja
ähm und dann Durchbruchsinfektion sehen wir gerade sehr viele, was wir nicht wussten, ist das auch eine Booster-Impfung mit Biontech Pfizer, das nicht verhindert, erklärte irgendwie Preisermitglied des Forschungskonsortiums, dass die Variante
entdeckt hat äh so äh und dann natürlich klar wieder der der übliche Disclaimer darf man natürlich nicht falsch verstehen, dass die Impfung nicht helfe, im Gegenteil.
Äh das zeigt nur, dass auch die bestmögliche Impfung offensichtlich nicht ausreicht, um eine Infektionsfälle. Was wäre schon geahnt haben?
Und ähm wir hatten auch verschiedene Kombinationen äh und so ähm wobei die meisten,
Biontech Olivan, also nur eine Person, also fünf waren Biontech, dreimal Biontech, eine war Biontech, Biontech Moderna und eine war Astrasenika, Biontech Biontech. So, das heißt,
man kann vermutlich wenn die Zahlen sind halt sehr sehr klein und wahrscheinlich weiß jetzt nicht wer die Auswahl war aber.
Ähm ja äh Kombiimpfung und da haben du und ich haben ja irgendwie jetzt ja äh du hast die Yolo Impfung, ich äh äh hatte jetzt äh.
Du auch. Du auch.
Ja, ja, ich hatte auch die gleiche Impfung, aber ich äh nenne sie äh nur nicht anders. Ich bin jetzt auf goldene Triarde äh bis äh bisher gekommen.
So so.
Ja. Genau. So und äh das das war jetzt
sagen nur dann genau der Punkt, den ich dann den Tag vorher hatte machen wollen, weil sie mir mich da nämlich gefragt hatte, äh war, ich meine, warum
okay also erstmal dass alle nur leichte Symptome haben, würde ich
auch von der Gruppe von dreifach geimpften jungen Deutschen auch nicht anders erwarten. So die Frage ist, was die Leute selber erwartet haben so. Also wie sie sich eigentlich jetzt angesteckt haben und wie sehr haben sie sich jetzt eigentlich auf ihre
Booster-Impfung äh verlassen. So oder und haben dann halt äh ja äh anderweitig Schutz genommen. Dann haben sie gesagt
äh irgendwie, ich bin geboostert
so was soll uns schon passieren und ich denke es spricht doch 'ne ganze Menge dafür ja oder wir wissen's einfach statistisch das.
Leute ähm,
einfach äh ihrer Impfung auch vertrauen und das tun sie halt auch zurecht äh natürlich und einer Booster-Impfung so ha dreifach irgendwie geboostert und ich erst mit drei verschiedenen Impfstoffen, ich meine ich müsste eigentlich jetzt
Superimmunität haben, habe ich wahrscheinlich auch so gegen Delta, also wahrscheinlich kann ich irgendwie jetzt
ja Delta haben wir wahrscheinlich jetzt wirklich nicht viel anhaben gerade aber dreht halt das ganze Spiel komplett.
Bei einem vielleicht ja also äh oder oder äh äh,
verändert halt äh die ganzen Gleichungen äh so und der Schutz, den halt wir jetzt gegen haben, ist ja wie ich das, wie ich das auf Total gesagt habe,
ist halt mehr so eine Schwimmhilfe äh als eine Rettungsweste, ja.
Gut, also jetzt will ich mir mal nicht so sehr in äh was könnte vielleicht unter Umständen sein, reinsteigern?
Nein, keine Frage, nehme ich sofort, aber sagen jetzt die also es zeichnet sich schon äh bereits ein Bild ab und,
Das sieht sieht halt nicht nicht gut aus so. Ähm also mal gucken, wenn Omikron hier das Land überrollt. Ich meine, klar, Masken und äh Kontaktreduzierungen helfen
sicherlich auch gegen OmiCronn, aber muss halt dann noch mehr Kontakte reduzieren, äh um dem einen halt äh zu gebieten und.
Die Impfung hilft auch, klar, aber äh reicht halt nicht. Dürfte alleine nicht ausreichen, um die Ausbreitung äh zu stoppen, selbst wenn 100 Prozent geimpft werden.
Und.
Ähm irgendwie herrscht scheinbar gerade auch noch äh trotz allem die die Meinung vor, wir könnten uns jetzt gerade rauspustern äh aus der aus der aktuellen Welle, aber das läuft ja gerade auch nicht. Äh so.
Lass doch mal auf die Situation in äh Südafrika schauen. Also die Frage der Herkunft, der Variante ist noch unklar. Ich habe das nicht so im Detail verfolgt soweit ich das ähm.
Bekommen habe, ist eine Variante, die diskutiert wird, dass es so ausm Nachbarland ähm von.
Südafrika kommt, Botswana oder sowas ähm.
Generell ist es ja so ein bisschen ein Rätsel mit Omicron durch diese hohe Zahl an Mutationen. Ähm warum ist das ein Thema? Einerseits natürlich, weil man jetzt in der Situation ist, so aha okay, viele
Mutationen bedeutet eben Impfstoffe et cetera. Passt nicht, haben wir ja jetzt schon ausführlich besprochen, sondern ist auch ein bisschen die Frage, wo kommt's denn auf einmal her? Denn,
Normalerweise kann man ja diese Varianten immer schön zurückverfolgen und das hat sich dort abgespalten, das hat sich dort abgespalten
Nicht alles sequenziert wird, aber man merkt eben schon, wenn PCR-Test nicht mehr so anschlagen und dann wird dann doch immer mal wieder hier, mehr oder weniger äh sequenziert,
Irgendwie kriegt man's mit und man kriegt vielleicht nicht jede Generation mit oder zumindest ist die Ketten nicht unbedingt sofort klar, aber das Puzzle
baut sich so über die Zeit langsam zusammen.
Im Fall von Ombron ist es aber etwas ominös, weil das letzte, worauf man das in irgendeiner Form noch zurückführen kann, ist eine Variante, die äh zuletzt zwanzigzwanzig im Sommer gesehen wurde, also schon 15 Monate her.
Und das stellt sich natürlich schon die Frage wie kann das jetzt eigentlich sein? So und es gibt mehrere äh
die unbeantwortet sind und vielleicht auch unbeantwortet bleiben. Wie das passieren kann. Das eine ist und das
wir glaube ich auch schon bei Alpha schon mal diese äh Debatte, dass so etwas durchaus beobachtet wird in
Körpern von Immunse äh supremierten Menschen, also die entweder generell ein schwaches äh Immunsystem haben oder die durch Krebs oder andere Krankheiten entsprechend ähm geschwächt sind. Auch äh Aids war hier in der Diskussion wird aber glaube ich, sobald ich das sehe, erst mal ausgeschlossen, dass das jetzt der Grund sein kann.
Auf jeden Fall äh ist es durchaus vorstellbar und wohl auch schon beobachtet worden, dass so ein Virus aus dem Körper nicht so richtig rauskommt. Also dass der quasi nicht weggekämpft wird, weil einfach das Immunsystem so schwach ist.
Dass Leute einfach über sehr langen Zeitraum, also wirklich über viele, viele, viele Monate dieses Virus einfach nicht loswerden. Der Körper einfach nicht in der Lage ist, äh es final zu killen. Und das bedeutet, das Virus ist da repliziert sich die ganze Zeit.
Ist vielleicht in so einem Modus, wo.
Es halt nicht umbringt, aber es eben auch nicht weg ist und na ja, was macht so ein Virus, wenn's eben sich die ganze Zeit repliziert ist, mutiert halt vor sich hin? Und wenn dann eben am Ende einer solchen Kette das Virus dann trotzdem den Körper wieder verlässt,
Was er sein kann über Ansteckung, so dann na ja, dann hast du auf einmal so einen Sprung. Zweite Variante, die diskutiert wird, ist, dass das Ganze jetzt in einem Land,
vor sich hin mutiert ist, wo eben die ganze Beobachtung der Pandemie nicht so ausgeprägt ist und auch das
natürlich wieder für das ein oder andere afrikanische Land, wo das dann vielleicht in
ländlichen Regionen äh umhergegangen ist und jetzt über wirklich einen längeren Zeitraum mehr oder weniger unbeobachtet äh sich weiter mutiert hat.
Ähm um dann irgendwann wieder
jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt in die Zivilisation äh zurückzukehren, aber halt sagen wir mal in in in stärker äh bevölkerte Gebiete und äh Urbanerer, industrialisiertere äh Gebiete zurückkehrt, wo es dann eben wieder
Teil der medizinischen Beobachtung geworden ist.
Und eine dritte Variante, es gibt einen schönen Artikel von äh Lars Fischer äh dazu mhm beim äh Science Blocks äh ist.
Dass es eben unter Umständen auch sein kann, dass diese Variante über die Tiere,
wieder zu uns zurückgekehrt ist. Also das Katzenhunde und viele andere Tiere sich ähm auch mit Corona anstecken können, weiß man ja mittlerweile.
Und wir wissen auch, dass es manche Tiere gibt, wie die Nerze zum Beispiel. Ja, wir hatten ja da diesen großen Corona-Befall, Dänemark, wo dann die ganzen Nerzbestände gekeult wurden und auch noch äh Holland gab's das.
Dass dass sich äh grad die Coronaviren in in diesen Tieren also ganz wunderbar wohlfühlen und sich wieder wunderbar replizieren und so wie es ja ohnehin eigentlich immer noch These Nummer eins ist, dass SARS-CoV-zwei,
über die Tiere äh letzten Endes zu uns gekommen ist, ähm kann es natürlich sehr wohl sein.
Die Pandemie der Menschen, das auch an Tiere gegeben hat, dass sich in Tieren weiter mutiert hat und jetzt wieder zurück zu uns gekommen ist.
Also das ist sind jetzt erstmal nur so drei Bilder, die klar machen sollen,
wie außergewöhnlich jetzt eigentlich diese Variante ist und Drosten meinte ja auch er hätte eben so einen hohen Grad an Mutation so früh nicht erwartet,
irgendwann vielleicht nächstes Jahr, aber eben nicht unbedingt jetzt. Und irgend so eine Art.
Brandbeschleuniger wird es hier gegeben haben. Das wird man vielleicht nochmal rausfinden, vielleicht wird es aber auch einfach komplett
unbekannt sein. Nichtsdestotrotz aufgetaucht ist diese Variante
Jetzt zuerst, also beobachtet worden, richtig und äh segmentiert, ist sie halt in Südafrika, speziell in der Gotengrovinz, also das ist da die Gegend um Johannesburg und äh Pretoria.
Und wird natürlich jetzt mit Argusaugen beobachtet. Man schaut sich eben die Inzidenzen an. Die sind enorm, also äh ingouten ist, glaube ich, jetzt auch schon irgendwie bei hundert Prozent. Also da gibt's irgendwie schon gar nichts anderes mehr als ähm OmiCon.
Und so verbreitet sich das eben auch grade schlagartig in
Südafrika und um das jetzt mal kontextualisieren zu können, muss man sich mal klar machen, was eigentlich bisher in Südafrika passiert ist. So, ne, also previewsly äh und Corona in Afrika. So
Klar, da ist der Wildtyp aufgetaucht,
Später gab's dann äh die Beta-Variante äh als Welle. Da sind sie irgendwie alle durchgegangen. Ähm dann kam Delta. Das ist auch alles noch mal durchgegangen und da hat irgendwie auch eine massive Durchseuchung stattgefunden.
Klar, ein paar Leute sind auch geimpft, aber im Wesentlichen, die Impfquoten sind verhältnismäßig niedrig, aber die Infektionszahlen waren halt
hoch und man kann halt davon ausgehen, dass äh in Südafrika eine extrem hohe äh natürliche Immunität vorherrscht, einfach weil so viele Leute sich damit infiziert haben.
Land ne und so weiter. Deswegen nicht ganz so viele Fälle, aber die hatten natürlich auch ihre Probleme damit. Und jetzt kommt Omikron. Jetzt geht es sozusagen in so einer
extrem schon mit dem Virus bemalten Gesellschaft gefühlt noch mal von vorne los.
Und jetzt schaut man natürlich drauf und guckt, okay, was passiert denn jetzt, ne? Virusvariante mit so einem hohen R0 und das sind jetzt noch unfertige Beobachtungen.
Die Zahl der Krankenhaus, Einweisung in Südafrika gehen jetzt hoch.
Man ja eigentlich auch erwarten, wenn so hohe Inzidenzen sind. Das geht also so total durch die Decke. Ich kann das jetzt gerade nicht in Relation setzen, aber es
auf jeden Fall jetzt schon klar, dass es sehr viel steiler ansteigt als das ähm mit Delta und allen anderen Varianten der Fall war.
Sieht man auch da dran, dass eben jetzt schon sozusagen 100Prozent aller gemessenen äh Infizierungen.
Auf diese Variante zurückzuführen sind. Das ist einfach überall und äh geht einfach schnell rum. Ja und äh die.
Situation ist. Klar, es gibt mehr Krankenhauseinweisungen nur nicht in dem selben Maße, zumindest noch nicht,
ähm so schwere Verläufe. Ist ein bisschen wackeliges Datenmaterial, mit dem wir da jetzt hier arbeiten, nicht
zum Wesentlichen die Beobachtung anderer Leute wieder, die sich die Situation und die Zahlen anschauen, ihre Interpretationen machen, sehr ähm lohnenswert ist, vor allem
diese Videoserie von dem John Campbell, so ein britischer,
Ähm Wissenschaftler, der sich schon seit Längerem die ganze äh Coronakrise auch äh immer mit anschaut und Zahlen interpretiert und und und Studien äh vorstellt et cetera.
Diese Situation genauer angeschaut hat und meint so na ja aus seiner Perspektive gibt's durchaus auch positive Nachrichten.
Weil es irgendwie,
zumindest eben in Südafrika mit dieser Brille, Südafrika, mit diesem Hintergrund, mit dieser Altersverteilung, ne, immer im Hintergrund halten. Ähm das.
Verhältnis zu diesen Inzidenzen zumindest noch nicht äh ein totales Drama sich abspielt in den Krankenhäusern.
Das muss in Deutschland nicht genauso laufen, weil wir haben nicht diese massive Infektion und wir haben eben aber auch nicht eine ausreichend hohe.
Impfabdeckung.
Hätten wir die, wäre es vielleicht vergleichbar, aber da wir die nicht haben, weil uns diese zwanzig Prozent fehlen, kann eben Omikon hier auch noch schwer einschlagen und gerade da
viele alte noch nicht ausreichend geimpft sind und nicht geboostert sind, kann das eben dann auch wirklich wieder sehr sehr sehr deadly werden, einfach weil
in dem Moment, wo es losgeht mit der Infektion, geht's dann halt einfach rattenschnell, weil das Ding eben so einen hohen R0 hat. Aber in äh Südafrika, wo eben die Grundanlage etwas anders ist, zeichnet sich zumindest äh ab.
Ausbreitung hoch, aber der Schaden noch überschaubar in dem Moment, wo man so eine Grundimmuntür hat. Das heißt, was Omikron wahrscheinlich ist.
Ist so die erste, indemische Variante. Also das, was wir eigentlich in Anführungsstrichen.
Sein könnte.
Haben wollen, ja, genau sein könnte, genau sein könnte, ähm heißt, geht rum, alle kriegen das,
aber es schadet der Bevölkerung nicht mehr in dem Maße.
Das alles komplett auf Alarm gestellt werden musstest. Vielleicht etwas, was man auch noch abfedern muss und wo es auch immer noch sinnvoll ist.
Masken zu tragen, zumindest so in äh extremen Fällen. Aber wo man jetzt nicht sagt, okay äh das bringt uns jetzt alle um.
Und die Gründe dafür sind vielseitig, du hast ja schon
eins auch angesprochen. Das ist so eine Studie, die rausgekommen ist. Das muss man jetzt noch mal abwarten, was das bedeutet, aber die haben sich halt natürlich auch diesen
genetischen Code angeschaut und festgestellt, so aha, mhm, eine dieser Mutationen kommt so eins zu eins aus so einem anderen Coronavirus.
So ein so ein typischer Schnupfen Virus.
Und äh das kann halt bedeuten, dass sich eben ähm ja, sich da einfach auch zwei Coronaviren äh gekreuzt haben, die halt irgendwie gleichzeitig
in einem Körper äh waren und das eben diese Virusvariante da sich vielleicht so.
Diese Ansteckungsoptimierung geholt hat, ne, weil Schnupfen geht ja immer gut rum. Kennen wir ja alle. Irgendeiner schnieft im Raum und dann schnieft man auch.
Das ist halt leichte Ansteckung. Das äh könnte dort eben übernommen worden sein, aber es könnte eben auch ein Hergehen mit, bringt aber nicht gleich seinen Host um,
Also, dass das Ding so etwas entschärft ist besser sich verbreitet, aber nicht alle killt. Das ist ja eigentlich für so einen Virus optimal. Nur.
Funktioniert das eben auch nur.
Dann ohne viel Schaden, wenn eben das auch schon ein paar Mal rum war und die Gesellschaft das schon gesehen hat und das ist bei uns halt einfach noch nicht der Fall.
Sprich Omikron könnte unter Umständen vielleicht unter Umständen schon so der Vorbote so ein bisschen so der Anfang vom Ende sein,
nur müssen wir uns erstmal in diese Position reinimpfen, dass das das für uns auch wirklich bedeuten kann.
Und.
Risiken, ältere Bevölkerung und ein Risiko besteht halt auch in der Dynamik, wenn's halt sehr sehr schnell geht. So ist es halt das Gegenteil von flitten the Curves, sondern das ist halt dann mehr sagen, wenn's sich dann zu so einem.
Tsunami äh entwickelt, äh der sich dann äh zu einer richtig hohen Welle aufbaut, dann äh.
Kann das halt selbst wenn ich sag mal der nur
ein Drittel oder ein Viertel äh so schlimm ist, äh sage ich mal, aber die Inzidenzen jetzt plötzlich zehnmal so hoch sind, ja.
Dann hast du trotzdem noch äh in der in der äh Menge äh plötzlich eine sehr sehr extreme Belastung äh des.
Gesundheitssystem so und ich hätte.
Ich meine, weil wer jetzt schon so viel spekuliert haben über sagen, wo könnte der Virus jetzt herkommen? Wollte ich auch noch meinen meinen Senf äh dazu tun und dann auch,
äh gleich mit einer kleinen Verschwörungstheorie und allerdings auch gleich dazu dahinter sagen werde, warum ich die auch nicht wiederum nicht für sehr wahrscheinlich halte, aber ich habe,
trotzdem schön äh die Verschwörungstheorie, weil äh ja äh und zwar äh
als du sagtest, ja hm, was haben wir jetzt irgendwie zum letzten Mal vor zwei Jahren äh gesehen und seitdem war's irgendwie haben wir's nirgendwo irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit
beobachtet und äh ja wo war's denn die ganze Zeit? Und da habe ich mir na ja hm äh es erinnert mich ja an diese Felle, wo dann plötzlich eine Leiche auftaucht und noch total frisch ist nach zwei Jahren und eigentlich aber irgendwie seit zwei Jahren verschwunden war.
Und ähm ja was äh wenn sich das irgendwie in dem Kühlschrank befunden hat, äh halt äh die ganze Zeit beziehungsweise in einem Labor.
Und genau und irgendjemand versucht hat äh irgendwie gezielt einen äh äh Coronavirus zu bauen oder zu kreuzen,
einem harmlosen Virus, um äh sagen genau diesen Effekt äh äh zu äh erzielen. So ähm.
Ja äh gut und äh natürlich also es ist halt ich halte es ähm einfach deswegen,
für unwahrscheinlich, äh weil wir im Labor nicht in der Lage sind, so den äh notwendigen, evolutionären Druck
zu erzeugen, der jetzt irgendwie also da müsste man schon Experimente an an Menschen, mal an vielleicht Nordkorea wäre dann noch äh würde dann.
Pavel.
Aber äh nee.
Sitzt den Leuten kein Floh ins Ohr.
Der der äh ja, ja. Äh wie gesagt, aber ich äh äh bezweifle äh einfach äh stark äh äh wie gesagt, dass wir die Fähigkeiten haben, äh also im im Labor so etwas hinzukriegen, weil was
halt das Problem an all den Theorien ist, die du vorhin geäußert hast oder generell äh das Problem mit den Theorien, dass sich das irgendwie in einer
immungeschwächten äh Personen entwickelt hat, die außerdem noch mit irgendwie mehreren Viren äh infiziert war, ist
dass aber sich dann wenn so ein Virus innerhalb eines Organismus
hin und her mutiert, äh er sich eher dann auf ein
an einen auch schwaches Immunsystem anpasst oder an ein spezielles Immunsystem, äh was halt für die individuelle äh Situation äh da ist und dann eben eher schlechtere Chancen hat,
in der breiten Bevölkerung ähm erfolgreich zu sein, so. Insofern äh
ja, ist es ist es halt äh ähm,
schwierig und ich glaube nicht, dass wir wirklich jemals dahinter kommen werden äh was was wirklich äh passiert ist, aber interessant an der Geschichte finde ich noch.
Ähm dass ich äh oder wir das ja mal vor
fast einem Jahr oder so haben wir mal über das Thema Varianten diskutiert, hatte ich auch einen längeren darüber geschrieben, wie denn so die in welche Richtung sich denn so die Varianten entwickeln können und was denn passiert, wenn jetzt,
jemand sich mit mehreren Varianten ansteck
und die Viren dann quasi Sex äh haben und so und dann wurde halt von Fachleuten eingewandt, na ja aber
Das erfordert äh sogenannte Homologe Rekombination und das machen RNA-Viren nicht, die sind halt irgendwie alle äh äh zu stabil dafür. Also sprich, die sind halt die
ja Viren haben keinen Sex, also Homologe-Rekombination, wenn man sich so vorstellen noch, dass halt
äh einfach bestimmte Virusabschnitte gegen denselben Virusabschnitt äh aus einer anderen Quelle äh ausgetauscht werden so. Ähm
es gibt aber einen weiteren Mechanismus in äh RNA äh äh Viren, was die nämlich machen bei der Replikation. Das fand ich auch total faszinierend, ist sogenanntes Templay-Switching. Äh
Template ist in dem Fall einfach die Kopiervorlage, das Stück RNA, wo sie jetzt von abschreiben.
Und was sie dann einfach machen so an bestimmten Stellen ist einfach auf eine andere idealerweise identische Vorlage zu wechseln.
Ähm so und das tun sie quasi als
Kopierschutz oder oder um sicherzustellen, äh dass äh sie auch die richtige Kopie äh haben. Da finde ich ein super Algorithmus, weil
Quasi sie wechseln dann die Vorlage.
Äh wenn sie dann irgendwie aus der Spur gekommen sind. Ja, was weiß ich, irgendwo was vergessen haben oder irgendwo Fehler drin sind und dann misslingt halt der Sprung auf die neue Kopie, die die eine andere
Vorlage passt nicht und damit ist irgendwie Fehler und dann wird das halt rejectet und äh äh ja. Ähm.
Aber dieser Mechanismus kann natürlich auch versagen, das heißt äh äh das Template kann dann quasi, wenn du von mehreren Viren infiziert bist, kann das Template dann als Kopiervorlage
auf eine RNA von einem anderen Virus überswitchen und so halt,
quasi Genome von äh zwei verschiedenen Viren rekonbinieren. Fand ich so äh ist bisschen nerdig, aber fand ich irgendwie interessant.
Äh mal sagen, solche molekularen Mechanismen, äh die vielleicht dahinter stecken könnten, äh äh hinter sowas, also hinter der Entstehung von OmiCron jetzt.
Nochmal, was so jetzt mit was war jetzt so mit Unikron so?
Machen äh und was es noch so äh bewirkt. Also andere Beobachtungen, ich beziehe mich jetzt noch mal auf dieses Video von dem John äh Campbell. Äh der meinte halt so, na ja, also erst mal
bei diesen ganzen Krankenhausaufnahmen war das so, dass ähm zwar bei sehr vielen Leuten.
Eine Infektion festgestellt wurde, aber 3 Viertel davon.
Überhaupt nicht wegen irgendwelcher typischen Symptome eingeliefert wurden. Das heißt, die waren infiziert, wussten es gar nicht, waren aber irgendwie aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen und Erwägungen ähm,
im Krankenhaus, wobei ich mich dann halt frage, wenn es 75 Prozent sind, wie erklärt das? Also wie passt das dann zusammen mit dieser hohen Zahl, also Zunahme? Also vielleicht waren's schon irgendwelche Dinge, die sie so,
zum Krankenhaus gebracht haben, aber halt nicht unbedingt so das Typische, was man bisher mit Corona verbunden hat, also dass da eine andere Symptomatik ist. Andererseits ähm ist wohl auch die.
Verweildauer die durchschnittliche Weildauer deutlich nach unten gegangen. Also während man so bei Delta-Achteinhalbtage im Schnitt gesehen hat und das jetzt hier irgendwie derzeit nur 22,8 Tage.
Also zwar Krankenhaus, aber eben nicht so viel Krankenhaus.
Und was auch wiederum aus dem anderen.
Äh Bericht äh ich ich entnommen habe, den der Kempel glaube ich aber auch zitiert hat, war äh dass tatsächlich die Symptomatik
eben sich doch deutlich unterscheidet, äh dass es irgendwie gar kein SARS so richtig zu sein scheint, ja, covid, aber nicht SARS, also Sevilla Cute, Raspiratory Syndrome scheint nicht so zu den
Symptomen zu gehören, sondern eher äh wohl hauptsächlich Müdigkeit äh äh Kopfschmerzen ähm.
So in in der Richtung. Äh so äh Schwäche ähm
ja bisschen Kreislaufprobleme, Schüttelfrost, ja Schüttelfrost gehört wohl noch dazu, aber eben
ähm Atem aber nicht, aber kein Schnupfen, kein Husten ja. Äh so
das wurde zumindest dort auch auch berichtet und wenn sich das bewahrheitet, ja dann sollen wir das eigentlich in NonsARS-CoV3 oder so umbenennen.
Covid 12und.
Oder Covid 12und.
Ja, das wird sich alles noch zeigen und wie gesagt, man kann halt
relativ wenig jetzt aus der Situation in Südafrika für uns ableiten, einfach weil,
Ja, unsere Infektionslage einfach anders ist, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, wir werden nicht so lange warten, bis wir hier neue Erkenntnisse haben. Also ich schätze mal so in zwei, drei Wochen werden wir da eine Menge von sehen.
Vielleicht noch nicht unbedingt jetzt überall in Deutschland, aber zumindest in Europa und ähm ja, dann wissen wir auch schon mehr.
Und äh wie gesagt, ich denke noch mal, das Resümee Booster lassen, aber sich nichts äh darauf äh.
Bilden äh so, sondern gerade wegen also um immer wichtig ist es jetzt halt auch ein bisschen Zeit zu gewinnen äh äh und
die
umikron äh Ausbreitung dadurch zu begrenzen, dass man halt äh ja einfach sich so verhält, als wär's alles nur um Mikron und als wäre man infiziert, weil ähm auch tatsächlich,
Omikron bei Geimpften äh der Großteil gar nicht weiß, äh dass der infiziert und infektiös ist. Das ist wirklich offenbar.
Äh bei ganz vielen Leuten weitgehend symptomfrei abläuft, weil eben teilweise,
typischen Symptomen ja, kein kein Schnupfen, kein Husten, kommst du auch nicht auf die Idee, das so covid haben könntest, oder? Wenn du kein Husten oder kein Schnupfen hast.
Ja, also irgendwas muss ja schon drauf hinweisen.
Ja, ja. Und deshalb, ja, also pustern, aber nichts drauf einbilden, sondern äh.
Maximal vorsichtig sein und Masken und kontaktreduzierung und was immer irgendwie möglich ist äh keine großen Menschenansammlungen äh zumindest nicht ungeschützt lieber.
Draußen als drinnen treffen, wenn man sich mit vielen Leuten treffen möchte.
Auch noch ähm bisschen äh offen ist, ist so die Auswirkung auf Kinder, also derzeit wird auch beobachtet, dass Kinder sehr viel mehr betroffen sind als das bisher bei den Varianten der Fall war.
Ja, dass er einfach mehr Infektionen gesehen ist. Das kann jetzt halt einfach generell mit der höheren Infektiösität zu tun haben, dass es sich dann halt einfach jetzt bei Kindern mehr äh durchsetzt als bisher. Ich glaube, das haben wir eigentlich auch bei Delta schon gesehen.
Also so richtig unerklärlich erscheint mir das jetzt nicht äh zu sein.
Aber auch hier ist noch viel zu früh, um da irgendwelche Aussagen zu machen. Ich glaube, die einzige Aussage, die sich halten lässt, ist.
Es wird kommen und es wird die dominante Variante sein in der nächsten Zeit.
Da müssen wir gucken wie wir damit klar kommen aber wenn man sich jetzt erstmal noch für die Restzeit gegen Delta schützt ist es auf jeden Fall kein.
Fehler und schafft schon mal die Voraussetzungen, sich auch von einer noch infektiöseren Variante nicht äh aus der Bahn werfen zu lassen.
Und das jetzt mal mit.
Irgendwie nochmal mit mit unschönen Zahlen äh zu füllen was das denn bedeuten würde, wenn äh äh OmiCon äh jetzt einmal äh durch die gesamte Bevölkerung geht,
Äh dann äh ja äh würden wir trotzdem auf 200.000 Tote kommen, selbst
unter der Annahme äh dass alle geimpft sind. Äh ja also da dass wir halt eine selbst mit neunzig oder fünf9und Prozent Impfquote wenn das durchlauft durchläuft würden trotzdem 2hundert000 Leute
sterben irgendwie wenn das nicht
deutlich harmloser ist, sondern wenn das halt ungefähr so gefährlich ist äh wie halt äh ja äh Delta auch. Äh wenn man einmal,
infiziert,
ist und ähm äh ohne ich meine ohne Impfung äh könnte es äh wahrscheinlich sogar keine Ahnung fünf zwischen fünfhundert, tausend und einer Million äh äh Tote äh werden. Insofern.
Ist äh Impfung,
auf auf jeden Fall ähm ja äh rettet äh Menschenleben in äh ja im hunderttausender Bereich, wenn man,
dann mal äh am ans bis ans Ende äh schaut oder auch.
Darauf guckt was was uns bisher äh schon hätte hätte Kultur gedroht hätte, aber äh ja der der der Punkt ist,
wenn ähm wenn es nicht,
harmlos ist, wovon wir jetzt nicht ausgehen sollten. Ähm doppelte Verneinung, sorry. Ähm also wenn's gefährlich ist, wovon wir.
Im Moment noch ausgehen sollten.
Äh so äh und wenn es so ansteckend ist und die Impfung durchbricht, dann bleiben uns eben nur äh die äh konventionellen äh Wege, um dem Einhalt zu gebieten und die Impfung um den Impact
zu äh begrenzen. So aber die Impfung alleine wird einfach dann nicht ausreichen, um die Katastrophe abzuwenden.
Ja beziehungsweise ähm ja neue
Impfstoffe, aber da wissen wir auch, dass das mindestens jetzt drei Monate noch dauern wird. Also im März, also vor März wird ja nichts äh äh Neues
erwartet
und dann geht jetzt auch schon wieder die Debatte los, okay Kai wird's jetzt ein Kombi-Impfstoff geben oder kann es einen Kombi-Impfstoff geben, der irgendwie gegen Delta und die neue Variante. Also und Antwort ist wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern wahrscheinlich müsste man braucht man dann trotzdem irgendwie
zwei Impfungen gegen beide Varianten äh äh das ist zumindest mein Stand. Insofern macht es dann auch Sinn sich jetzt irgendwie Boostern
zu lassen allein schon deswegen weil sagen die der neue Impfstoff dann wahrscheinlich kein Ersatz sondern ein Zusatz äh nochmal sein wird und dass man dann trotzdem die ganze Delta-Serie braucht.
So, aber gut, wir werden sehen, aber das ist zumindest das, was ich gehört habe.
Aber äh wir werden uns auf jeden Fall werden uns neue Impfstoffe und leider auch die alten äh äh alleine äh nicht retten.
Oder nimmt die Katastrophe alleine nicht abwenden. So viel steht glaube ich schon fest. Außer.
Die Neuen vielleicht schon, also das wissen wir ja auch nicht.
Die Neuen kommen, ich deswegen sage ich ja, in den nächsten drei Monaten äh äh wird da nichts kommen an an neuen
Impf äh äh Stoffen so. Äh deswegen werden's in den nächsten drei Monaten wieder die Neuen, noch die alten äh äh so. Oder wenn man so in den.
In der ersten Hälfte also die nächsten sechs Wochen generell äh wird's äh wird's halt helfen wie gesagt,
die Folgen auf ein Drittel zu begrenzen die Impferei und Boosterei äh so aber ein Drittel ist
reicht halt nicht aus. Also wir wollen auch glaube ich keine zweihunderttausend Toten und natürlich erst recht nicht sechshunderttausend.
Nee und auch kein Long Covid und überhaupt und es muss ja auch alles mal ein Ende finden, also äh wir haben's jetzt eigentlich äh äh selber in der Hand, aber äh wir müssen dann halt einfach die,
Instrumente machen. Also Biontech, Moderner und so weiter sind alle schon unterwegs und äh sagen Anpassung, alles überhaupt gar kein Problem, ist ja auch klar. Sie müssen letzten Endes nur den Code quasi ändern und äh an der ganzen Impfstoffproduktion
bleibt äh eigentlich alles gleich. Ähm die Frage ist, wie wird dann genau der Zulassungsprozess aussehen?
Ich mache mir da relativ wenig Sorgen, dass das so schnell wie's irgendwie möglich ist
geht, aber natürlich eine gewisse Sorgfalt auch an den Tag gelegt werden. Sollte ähm da sind sich glaube ich auch alle einig und äh bisher schwebt so was wie 100 Tage im Raum, also dass man dann sozusagen in drei Monaten so weit
sein könnte, die Produktion entsprechend umzustellen und dann ja hätte man quasi
Die vierte Impfung am Start, ne, also dann kommt sozusagen der OmiCronbooster.
Ähm die man dann nochmal nachschmeißt und dann äh könnte sich eben auch der Sommer dann wieder äh relativ entspannt entwickeln. So wird dann jetzt alle mitziehen und äh das mit der Impfpflicht greift natürlich.
Ja, dann vielleicht noch eine Sache hinterher.
Omikron, schließen wir jetzt mal hier äh ab. Noch ein paar Links in den äh die ich äh relevant fand, weil das darf man auch dabei nicht vergessen. Euer bester Schutz mal abgesehen vom Impfen sind Masken.
Und ähm wer das noch nicht äh gecheckt hat, sollte einfach mal generell auf FFP2-Masken umsteigen, die ich übrigens nicht nur besser finde, weil sie besser sind, sondern weil ich sie eigentlich auch generell für praktische halte.
Ja also letzte Mal schon festgestellt so Leute mit.
Hatten wir das hier gemacht oder war das Boutique? Ich weiß grad gar nicht mehr. Auf jeden Fall so dieses Tragen von diesen normalen Mund-Nase-Schutz äh äh Dingern weiß ich nicht.
Die Dinger verleiten einfach dazu falsch getragen zu werden. Ähm aber Studien haben jetzt auch nochmal belegt, wie gut diese Masken schützen, also und zwar richtig gut. Also wenn sie richtig an.
Gelegt sind. Ja, Klammer auf. Wichtig, Klammer zu,
dann äh ist da wirklich von sehr hohem Schutz bis zu hundert Prozent die Rede. Also sprich, da kommt nix durch. Was heißt jetzt richtig angelegt? Ich sehe das sehr oft.
Ja, sehr oft ist ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ich sehe es zu oft, ähm dass Leute sich zwei F P 2 Masken aufsetzen, aber das oben mit diesem Nasenbügel irgendwie nicht verstanden haben.
Die passen den dann nicht an und dann liegt das Ding da so oben auf und hat da sozusagen so eine Luftkante.
Das ist natürlich ein echter Fehler. Also das äh das bisschen Nachdrücken, das sollte man sich also schon an äh gewöhnen, denn ihr müsst einfach davon ausgehen, gerade jetzt mit Omicron äh die Gefahr ist halt dann einfach wieder,
Indoor. Muss man einfach so sagen. Indoor ist einfach das Problem und äh solange wir so hohe Inzidenzen haben sowieso ähm und da sind einfach Masken äh,
der richtige Ansatz. Und wenn ihr euch immer schon drüber geärgert habt, dass die Masken nach einer Weile so nass geatmet sind, stellt sich raus, feuchte Masken schützen sogar noch besser als die Trockenen.
Ist also ein Feature, kein Bug.
Plus was ich gut ich bin jetzt nur ein Mal geflogen während der Pandemie jetzt mit
mit einer Maske. Es ist äh äh tatsächlich dann auch nochmal gesünder, weil die Atemluft
befeuchtet wird. Man hat quasi so einen leichten Atemluftbefeuchter äh äh dadurch, äh was halt auch gerade auf längeren Flügen
weiß nicht wer mal das Gefühl hatte nach einem längeren Flug plötzlich irgendwie,
so Jahr auf der dass die Lunge so ein bisschen brennt, dass man das Gefühl hatte irgendwie dann so eine leichte Lungenentzündung zu haben und das ist dann tatsächlich auch so, was dann hauptsächlich an der trockenen Luft
liegt auf Langstreckenflügen, die erzeugen dann eben äh quasi leichte Lungenentzündungen, weswegen man dann halt auch die als die Olymp
Olympia äh Olympiade in Australien war, äh hat man die ganzen Sportler dann mit
unter anderem mit Thrombosestrümpfen und aber mit spezieller Atemluftbefeuchtung auch in den Flieger gesetzt, weil das halt sonst äh ja.
Massiv ihre Gesundheit bedroht hätte und Masken sorgen dann halt so ein bisschen für die Atemluft Befeuchtung äh,
im im Fliegerhalle nochmal ein zusätzlicher Benefit.
Und wie gesagt, ein Schutzfaktor, Masken zehn bis dreißig ist äh interessanterweise das, was wir
seit keine Ahnung, anderthalb Jahren ungefähr hier so verbreiten und äh nicht, dass wir uns da jetzt was allzu viel drauf einbilden, vielleicht ein bisschen
ähm aber äh ja äh stellt sich raus, wir haben also auch in dem
Fall dann doch mit der Einschätzung richtig gelegen, ähm so, dass man sich jetzt bestätigt hat, äh das, was damals die wahrscheinlichste Vermutung äh war oder damals schon,
aus dem, was bekannt war, äh ähm wir uns richtig äh zurecht konstruiert haben, sage ich mal.
Und äh ja und äh vor allen Dingen auch nochmal euch noch ein Ding, wenn alle Masken tragen, erhöht sich nochmal der Effekt,
äh massiv. Also dann äh multipliziert sich quasi noch der Schutz.
Effekt, weil äh weniger äh Virus in der Luft ist und von dem, was weniger in der Luft ist, äh halt auch nur ein Bruchteil.
Eingeatmet wird, das heißt äh ja man dann quasi nochmal den den multiplizierten Schutz, wenn man so will. Nicht ganz, aber.
Bester aller Welten sozusagen. So, jetzt machen wir Schluss hier. Paville ähm.
Schon.
Ich habe erst drei Stunden.
Erste drei ja, nein, es es war ja, es ist.
Ist alles gesagt erstmal und äh wir haben ja jetzt auch schon äh beschlossen, wir machen jetzt erstmal wieder wöchentlich solange so viel äh Hekt
ist, von daher können wir das nachtragen. Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir auch so ein bisschen abgearbeitet, was sich so ein wenig angestaut hat. Ähm,
Dass wir dann vielleicht wieder ein bisschen mehr in den Update-Modus kommen. Das werden wir dann sehen. Äh ja, Ausblick haben wir wir haben jetzt schon so viel zum Ausblick gesagt. Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal äh ein Extrafazit machen, aber ihr wisst ja, äh,
Kurz gesagt, uffpassen, Maske tragen ist äh auf jeden Fall immer.
Hilfreich, durchblustern lassen, soweit ja irgendwie äh könnt ähm zur Terminverfügbarkeit kann ich euch relativ wenig sagen, müsst ihr halt schauen, aber es geht eigentlich ganz gut voran und dann seid ihr schon mal ganz gut gerüstet für Weihnachten.
Ja, also ich persönlich bin jetzt ja, wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe, ganz gut damit gefahren.
Statt irgendwie ewig am Internet zu hängen klar wenn man irgendwie dadurch eine besorgt kriegt auch gut
Aber äh äh dann halt hm ja zu gucken äh spontan
in den Randzeiten äh äh vielleicht äh bei einem Impfzentrum oder irgendwo wo geimpft wird äh aufzutauchen äh so ein bisschen außer der Zeit vielleicht, keine Ahnung Samstag früh oder
weiß ich nicht zu irgendwer kann vielleicht da auch,
anrufen oder mal irgendwie hören, was denn dann so die Hauptbesuchszeiten äh sind und dann eben äh versuchen halt äh
dazwischen zu rutschen und ja ich habe damit gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Aber ihr werdet schon was finden. Gut, dann äh verabschieden wir uns. Äh.
Mit dieser Ausgabe und wünschen euch äh noch eine angenehme Zeit und äh wir hören uns dann vielleicht nächste Woche äh wieder. Wenn ihr Lust habt, holt ihr euch noch ein schickes UKW äh Shirt äh in Mitterebene Einkaufsladen und äh dann geht's euch noch besser.
Also sagen wir tschüss.